So, moin, ich war heute nicht rennen, mir tun auch die Beine weh von gestern, ich hab's mal sein gelassen heute, eigentlich, eigentlich wär's heute dran, zweiter Tag, aber ich bin zweimal in Folge jetzt zusätzlich noch Fahrrad gefahren, es reicht.
Eins hab ich gemerkt, Leute, seit ich angefangen hab, mich ein bisschen mehr wieder zu bewegen, ich hab übelst Hunger, aber das ist auch nice, kann man mehr fressen, ohne großartig zuzunehmen.
Ich hab sogar schon wieder ein bisschen abgenommen, Sachen gibt's, ich hatte vor zwei Tagen neuen Tiefstand auf der Waage, oh, ich muss mein Mikrofon wieder umstöpseln, oh, ich hab keinen Bock, mein Mikrofon, ja, doch, ich stöpsel das Mikrofon gleich wieder auf, ja, mein Setup ist so krass pepege, Alter.
Wo ich jetzt bin? Achso, du meinst, äh, 91...
Warte mal, ich hab ein Foto, ich hab ein Foto gemacht, ich mach immer von Tiefständen Bilder, seck, 91,2, ja, normal hab ich immer zwischen 92 und 94 gehabt, je nachdem, wann man sich's wiegt, jetzt 91,2, und das war noch vorm Rennen vor zwei Tagen.
Also danach wär definitiv unter 91 gewesen, aber das ist auch kein Wunder, weil man einfach schwitzt, also 200 Gramm...
Es sind dann auf jeden Fall weg, aber das ist ja bescheuert, ich mein, man muss sich ja immer so halbwegs konsistent zu ähnlichen Zeiten wiegen, sonst macht das ja wenig Sinn.
Ich mein, es wiegt sich ja auch niemand, nachdem man gerade drei Schnitzel gefressen hat mittags oder so.
Oh nee, ich brauch ein bisschen...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Übertreib halt.
Übertreibt halt mit der Musik.
Das kann ich.
Haha.
Wie gesagt, 91,2.
Also ich denke mal, wenn ich das wirklich weitermache,
so mit Rennen jeden zweiten Tag und ab und zu mal Fahrrad fahren,
dann sind die, sind unter 100, äh nicht unter 100, unter 90 auf jeden Fall drin.
Bis Ende des Jahres.
Ist dann zwar ein Jahr verspätet, dieses Jahr habe ich ja kaum Progress gemacht,
ein paar hundert Gramm vielleicht weniger.
Aber jetzt, ich werde jetzt zumindest erstmal mit Fahrrad fahren,
warten bis ich ein bisschen besser eingestellt habe,
weil ich merke es heute immer noch in den Händen
und ich merke es sogar immer noch in meinen beiden Zeigefinger,
dass sie sich komisch anfühlen.
Also Sattelposition und Lenker und wie ich da drauf sitze,
ist einfach nur nicht so optimal.
Und mein Arsch tut weh, immer noch.
Wobei es deutlich, deutlich besser geworden ist.
Also ich denke, wenn ich jetzt nochmal 1-2 Tage warte,
ist das eben, eben Pop ist weg und es sollte dann auch zunehmend besser werden.
Und dann sind auch die Hände wieder okay.
Ich habe mir jetzt ein paar Handschuhe bestellt,
mit so, mit so, mit so, mit so, mit so Gelpads innen,
bis ich mich da dran gewöhnt habe.
Und dann muss ich wahrscheinlich meinen Lenker nochmal ein bisschen in einen anderen Winkel stellen.
Aber ist nice.
Ist wirklich, also das hätte ich nicht gedacht, Fahrrad fahren macht übelst Bock.
Ich bin seit 20 Jahren oder so nicht mehr, naja,
wie viel, na doch, doch, doch.
Ich bin seit 20 Jahren oder so kein Fahrrad mehr gefahren.
25 Kilometer gestern und dann, ähm, ne, vorgestern und gestern, gestern 32.
Ne, das stimmt so nicht.
Regeneration ist auch nicht unwichtig.
Und ich bin gestern schon gefahren, obwohl ich noch Muskelkater vom Tag vorher hatte.
Also ein bisschen sich ab und zu mal ausruhen, Tag ist auch nicht verkehrt.
Ja, das stimmt, stimmt auch.
Ja, also eins muss ich ja echt sagen.
Ich habe mir das Selbstsetz letztens erst mal angeguckt.
Und hoffentlich geht das noch.
Nein, nein.
Nitter.
Ich glaube, da kann man sich die Sachen noch gescheit anzeigen lassen.
Ja, weil Twitter selbst tut ja nicht mehr, ne.
Ist halt bescheuert.
Jetzt braucht man irgendwelche Third-Party-Seiten, um sich Twitter noch nochmal anzuhalten.
Okay, sorry, X.
X.
Ich vergaß.
So.
Genau.
Ähm, ich habe mir das selbst mal durch Twitter nur noch mit Account,
ne, Twitter ist mit, also es ist total hängen geblieben.
Guck mal.
Du kannst zwar noch auf ein Twitter-Profil gehen, ohne dich einzuloggen.
Das funktioniert.
Das Problem ist, die Tweets sind einfach unsortet.
Ich weiß nicht, was sich Elon Fivehead dabei gedacht hat in dem Fall.
Aber das ergibt für mich überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Warum stehen oben, ich meine, ja, das sind Tweets, die vielleicht viele Leute sich angeguckt haben.
Ja, das sind Tweets, die vielleicht viele Leute sich angeguckt haben.
Ja, aber, aber es ist trotzdem bescheuert, dass man nicht die Möglichkeit hat, die neuesten nach oben.
Deswegen, deswegen nehme ich jetzt mal einfach, einfach Nitter.
Und ich habe letztens hier so durchgeguckt, ja.
Ich habe ja angefangen, meine, meine Rennergebnisse zu posten vor nicht, nicht so langer Zeit.
Ja, guck, das war das erste, was ich gepostet habe hier.
Guck mal, da habe ich 8 Minuten 52 gebraucht.
Für den Kilometer.
Richtig lahm.
Und mein letzter Post, wo ich mir Mühe gegeben habe, war 5 Minuten 45 pro Kilometer.
Das sind halt einfach mal ziemlich genau 3 Minuten schneller.
Innerhalb von 20, ne Moment, innerhalb von 14. August zu 24, also sagen wir mal eineinhalb Monate.
Das geht doch echt klar.
Eigenes Twit.
A Bird Champ.
Nein.
Das, das, A Bird Champ ist, das, das muss irgendwie anders heißen.
Ähm, Empörungs-Champ könnte man das nennen.
Ja, warum habe ich plus 10 Puls?
Weil ich übelst gerannt bin, bis ich nicht mehr konnte, damit ich das geschafft habe.
Irgendwann musste auch mal Vollgas geben.
Ich habe letztens in einem Video gehört.
Wer nur long and slow läuft.
Oder nee, wie, wie, wie haben, wie haben die das gesagt?
Long and slow running produces long and slow runners.
Irgendwie sowas.
Ab und zu musst du mal Gas geben.
Ich renne ja nicht jedes Mal so.
Ab und zu musst du auch mal Gas geben.
Und meine Uhr ist schon der Meinung, ich müsste ein bisschen mehr kurzfristig sprinten und Pause machen.
Weil ich zu viel Ausdauer.
Ausdauer.
Ausdauermäßig trainiere und nie, und nie es übertreibe und dann Pause mache und wieder volle Pulle und so.
Darf man nicht so sehr danach gehen.
Man muss das machen, was sich irgendwie auch angenehm so anfühlt.
Sonst hat man keinen Bock mehr.
Die letzten 100 Meter wird gesprit, das, das auch.
Aber das reicht ja nicht.
Naja.
Aber eine Technikfrage.
Wieso sollte man Docker nutzen?
Das kommt immer auf den Kopf drauf an, was man machen will.
So pauschal.
Aber gut, das geht ja noch weiter.
Wieso sollte man Docker nutzen, wenn man auch extra User unter Linux erstellen kann?
Halt die Rechte für den User so beschränken, dass man von dem User aus nur auf das eigene Home-Verzeichnis zugreifen kann.
Das ist tatsächlich eine gute Frage.
Das kommt ein bisschen drauf an, was es ist.
Das kann durchaus sinnvoll sein.
Also, Docker hat erstmal einen ganz anderen Hintergrund als das, wofür es, ja, viele Leute heute eigentlich kennen.
So nach dem Motto.
Isolierte Anwendungen laufen.
Das ist eigentlich überhaupt nicht so wirklich der Hintergrund von Docker gewesen.
Der Hintergrund von Docker ist, und das ist auch das, wo ich der Meinung bin, dass es immer noch am besten ist, dafür zu verwenden,
nachvollziehbare Entwicklungs-Setups.
Also eines der Punkte.
Ich will nicht sagen der Grund, ja.
Nachvollziehbare Entwicklungs-Setups.
Um dieses Problem zu lösen, dass ein Entwickler sagt, ey, bei mir funktioniert es, warum funktioniert es bei dir nicht?
Dann baut man einen Container mit allen Abhängigkeiten, und jeder kann das Build, den Container, die Anwendung bei sich starten, und es läuft einfach.
So, das ist der eigentliche, so, mit eines der Hauptgedanken gewesen bei Docker.
Und das hast du natürlich bei einer einzelnen Linungskiste nicht.
Wenn du eine einzelne Linungskiste aufbaust, oder, du baust jetzt drei Linungskisten auf, bei dem ersten läuft die Anwendung, bei den anderen zwei nicht.
Du musst gucken, was installierst du für Packages nach, sonst wie.
Also, das.
Das Problem wollten die lösen.
Wenn du eh auf der Kiste drauf bist, wo es läuft, dann kannst du auch die Anwendung dreimal nebeneinander starten, wenn die in unterschiedlichen Verzeichnissen sind.
Ist das jetzt nicht so wild?
Natürlich ist ein Docker-Container nochmal ein bisschen besser sandboxed, im Vergleich zu normal gestarteten Anwendungen.
Und, was der große Vorteil ist, die Anwendungen selbst, die müssen halt nicht großartig weiter customised werden.
Ja, du musst keine Config großartig anpassen, dass es sich nicht in die Quere kommt, oder was auch immer, du kannst einfach die Anwendung starten, starten, starten, 20 mal parallel auf einer Kiste, und es stört keinen.
Für die Anwendung sieht das immer gleich aus.
Also, ich würde tatsächlich sagen, dass das reine Sandboxing, wenn man Anwendungen jetzt mit Docker laufen lässt, gar nicht mal so sehr der Hauptsich-, also diese Sicherheitssache, der hauptsächlich ausschlaggebende Punkt ist, warum man es macht.
Warum man es macht, sondern man macht es hauptsächlich, weil es simpler ist, mehrere Anwendungen nebeneinander laufen zu lassen, unabhängig voneinander, und dass die Anwendungen sich nicht in die Quere kommen.
Zum Beispiel, stell dir mal vor, normalerweise schreiben Anwendungen unter var log.
Das heißt, du musst dich auf jeden Fall unter Linux in irgendeiner Art und Weise, müssen die Anwendungen benannt sein, entweder nach Systemd, Services, wie auch immer, musst du die irgendwie unterscheiden, dass nicht alle Anwendungen nach var log meine Anwendung.log schreiben.
Das wäre nämlich ein bisschen doof.
Das Problem hast du in einem Docker-Container nicht.
Die schreiben alle in ihr Systemlog, das kannst du dir mit Docker angucken, oder noch besser, du sammelst die Logs natürlich irgendwie zentral ein.
Also, dieser Sandboxing-Aspekt ist gar, würde ich jetzt zumindest aus meiner Sicht so sagen, gar nicht mal so der hauptsächliche Security-Grund, warum alle Docker verwenden sollten.
Zumindest nicht in dem Fall.
Wenn man jetzt ein bisschen weiter geht in Richtung Container-Orchestrierung mit Kubernetes und sowas, das hat ja mit Docker jetzt nur noch am Rande zu tun.
Ich glaube, mittlerweile ist Kubernetes selbst komplett Docker-free, es ist nichts mehr von Docker drin.
Da sieht das Ganze natürlich ein bisschen anders aus, wie das mit Container-Isolierung aussieht.
Nichtsdestotrotz, wenn man Wert legt auf Isolierung von Anwendungen, also wenn man wirklich sicher sein möchte, dass Anwendung A nichts, aber auch wirklich gar nicht irgendwie zur Anwendung B da reingucken kann.
Sagen wir mal so, du bietest eine Dienstleistung an, keine Ahnung.
Du hast eine Zeiterfassungsabrechnungssoftware in der Cloud, also für den Kunde in der Cloud und du willst halt nicht, dass zufälligerweise auch bei irgendeinem Angriff oder was auch immer,
jemand von der Anwendung A die Daten von Anwendung B auslesen kann, weil es zwei komplett unterschiedlichen Leuten gehört.
Also wenn du wirklich ganz, ganz viel Wert auf Isolierung legst, es gibt natürlich verschiedene Zwischenstufen, du kannst anfangen mit verschiedenen Heimatverzeichnissen, du kannst mit SE-Linux, das ist eh für mich so.
Wie hat letztens auf der Arbeit einer gesagt?
SE-Linux ist der Endgegner für mich.
Das trifft es eigentlich ganz gut.
Also du kannst natürlich unterschiedliche User, unterschiedliche Heimatverzeichnisse, irgendwann fängst du noch an mit ACLs, dann kannst du auch anfangen mit SE-Linux, mit Docker-Containern, mit vielleicht gehärtetem Kubernetes-Zeug oder und wenn du wirklich richtig viel Wert auf Isolierung der Anwendung legst, dann kriegt jede Anwendung eine VM.
Und das ist somit das Beste, was du machen kannst.
Also wenn das dein Hauptaspekt ist, die Isolierung von unterschiedlichen Anwendungen, dann gibt es immer noch nichts besseres und nichts sichereres als VM.
Na gut, unterschiedliche Hardware, aber also VM ist mittlerweile so erprobt und Battle-Tested, so dann würde ich sagen, das ist okay.
Also wenn du da ganz, ganz sicher sein willst, ist das Beste tatsächlich, du startest mehrere VMs.
Und VMs müssen in der heutigen Zeit ja nicht mehr super schwergewichtig sein.
Es gibt ja jede Menge Lightweight.
Nichtsdestotrotz braucht eine VM natürlich immer mehr Leistung als ein Container.
Ja, das habe ich lange erzählt.
Reicht das als Antwort?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich so auf den Kern so...
Ja doch, eigentlich schon.
Moin.
Also wie gesagt, es macht in manchen Fällen auch einfach keinen Sinn.
Also wenn es dir reicht, dass du verschiedene User anlegst und dann die Anwendung mehrfach startest,
dann macht das... sprich nichts.
Also du musst die Anwendung nicht zwangsläufig vercontainerisieren.
Aber woran man jetzt beispielsweise sieht, ist, wenn das auf mehr als einem Server sein soll,
dann ist es natürlich toll, wenn du so ein Self-Contained Container Image hast, wo du weißt, wenn du das startest, ist alles dabei, was die Anwendung braucht.
Aber Docker ist halt hauptsächlich auch mal gedacht gewesen dafür, um das Problem zwischen Entwicklerkisten zu lösen, dass es bei dem einen geht und bei dem anderen nicht.
Und wenn man das so macht, dann ist es auch nicht so einfach.
ich renne nächstes jahr dann beim bei diesem challenge lauf mit easy sind nur
fünf kilometer oder so nähe mache ich nicht werde ich nicht mit rennen weil
das ist immer erst abends um 18 uhr oder so war so lang will ich nicht in
frankfurt bleiben habe letztens einen kleinen home server gebauten dort mit
enzim docker container gab funktioniert ganz gut aber geht man auch zeug zu ihr
da muss halt auch gucken dass man es nicht übertreibt also es ist cool wenn
man das macht damit man das lernt man lernt sowas teilweise mehr als wenn man
es auf der arbeit verwenden muss weil man einfach zeit hat sich in ruhe damit
auseinanderzusetzen und nicht irgendwas am ende bei rauskommen muss aber ich
habe beispielsweise keinerlei ansatz und keinerlei jack bei mir daheim für
irgendwelche kisten weder für die raspberry pi ist noch für meinen doch
für meinen hp server der hinten steht wozu da gibt es da gibt sie ich mache
ab und zu mal ein backup von der
von der von der als themen config oder von bonseller startup config
ansonsten haben sie in frankfurt da ist kein problem dass ihn der tausende
leute da ich stöpsel mal kurz VM ROBERT
um dass das wieder bisschen besser klingt sek eine runde muten Thanos
thirsto backup ersagen ja ich hab das wirklich so billig wie vorbeides der
stimmlich ganz
piles
aber ja prinzipiell schon so billig so billig wie geht also das ist ein job in
android der das der das macht ich glaube da macht das mit ersten einfach offene
externen usb platte und ich bin wie gesagt ich bin damit an nicht wirklich
glücklich ich wollte es nie haben ich bin damit auch nicht wirklich glücklich
aber es ist so viel im heimbereich immer noch eines der kleinst kleineren übel so
wirklich was gescheites was mich davon im heimbereich groß überzeugt irgendwie
einfach nicht so als sie da also wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich können
sich alle leute freuen die in sinology nass gekauft haben weil das echt eine
simple ganz gute oberfläche hat wo man einfach klicken kann und gut ist wenn
man sich möglichst wenig damit beschäftigen will aber ich will ja ich
will halt beides machen ich will viele einstellungsmöglichkeiten haben aber es
auch wenn ich keinen bock habe schnell und easy also so wieso nicht esx weil
du mit esx keine container mit irgendeinem frontend easy starten
kannst du kannst
mit proxmox kannst du kannst zwar container starten aber keine fertigen
images sondern doch fertige images aber keine docker images sondern irgendwie so
docker in lxc und so was da musste ich wieder selbst und container handling
kümmern und das ist einfach pain schämen ich bin auch mittlerweile kein großer
fan mehr von docker compose und auch für kubernetes cluster habe ich daheim kein
bock deswegen finde ich so einen so einen management frontend wie das android hat
für docker container oder sinology hat eigentlich ganz gut
trunas hätte das theoretisch auch aber tuners ist unter der haube ein kat 3 s
cluster klar klasse kann man nicht sagen quad 3 s also single note kubernetes mit
das ist im prinzip nur den helm install gui und das habe ich mal ausprobiert
tuners was container handling angeht das war grausam ich mich mal kurz das mikrofon
um da ich bin wieder da aber ich höre mich selbst noch nicht das heißt erst mal hier einstöpseln
Ja, jetzt höre ich mich wieder.
Exzellent.
Ne, Docker-Compose ist vollkommen in Ordnung,
aber irgendwie habe ich keinen Bock mehr
auf YAML-File, Docker-Compose
von Hand.
Seit ich hauptsächlich Kubernetes
verwende,
weiß ich nicht, habe ich
keinen Bock mehr auf Compose.
Und ich habe aber auch keinen Bock auf Kubernetes
bei mir daheim.
Naja, wenn es dafür gedacht ist, ist halt die Frage, warum sie
so viel Wert darauf legen, ein
UI anzubieten für Container,
und für Virtualisierung.
Also da fließt ja einiges
an Hirnschmalz bei denen rein.
Oh ne, bloß nicht.
Portena ist der Sack, Alter.
Das kann ich überhaupt nicht ab.
Also dann mache ich ja mittlerweile lieber
Docker auf Command-Line,
wenn es einfach nur darum geht, 2-3 Container
zu starten. Deswegen finde ich
so einen Management-UI wie in Unraid
gar nicht mal übel.
So sieht's aus.
So, dann lasst uns mal die wöchentlichen
Shit-Hub-Trends angucken.
Also, wenn du damit klarkommst,
es spricht überhaupt nichts dagegen, das zu benutzen.
Was würdest du
im kommerziellen Bereich für deinen
Anwendungsfall verwenden?
Wenn ich viele Container habe, dann würde ich
irgendeinen Managed-Kubernetes-Cluster nehmen.
Keinen selbst installierten.
Irgendeinen Managed-Kubernetes-Cluster.
Und wie man das managt, da gibt's dann wieder
die unterschiedlichsten
Ansätze.
Zurzeit das
angesagteste ist Flux,
oder Argo-CD.
Dass sich das automatisch aus
YAML-Anwendungsdefinitionen von einem
Git-Repo synkt.
Das ist so zur Zeit das,
worauf viele schwören.
In dem Bereich.
Gibt noch mehr, aber
Argo-CD und Flux sind so die
zwei, die mir jetzt so spontan einfallen.
Es gibt noch
Cloud-Bees,
oder irgendwie so
heißt das. Verwendet keiner.
Aber
Argo-CD,
das haben wir im Stream schon mal
gemacht.
Ist es ja auch.
Passt mal였 auf.
Was passt »drauf, Moment mal ich zeig dir,
dass das ist.
Das ist Weltraum Technik.
Das sind alles unterschiedliche Projekte
im Kubernetes Umfeld.
Das ist das der Cloud-Native-Computing
Foundation,
heißen die, glaube ich,
der Cloud-Native Computing Foundation,
cloud native interactive landscape alles klar das ist das ist tatsächlich was das
könnte man wahrscheinlich auch auf irgendeinem business ding einbauen weil
es nicht einfach geil anhört so und hier sehen wir jetzt das cloud native
computing foundation cloud native interactive landscape so und das sind
alles nicht als pdf das sind alles projekte das sind das sind projekte die
hier drinnen stehen es gibt natürlich noch viel mehr die sagen also im cloud
native kubernetes umfeld angesiedelt sind man kann das noch umstellen dass es
nur offizielle oder oder projekte die damit was zu tun haben einblendet da
sind es ein bisschen weniger aber ihr seht es sind immer noch
übelst übelst viele und natürlich muss man nicht alles können aber das ist
eines der hauptgründe warum das ganze cloud und vor allem kubernetes thema so
komplex ist weil kubernetes alleine wie sagt man so kattet es halt nicht guck
kubernetes hat hier ein ding ein ding ist da drin aber der rest hält hängt
irgendwie na gut die gpc jetzt vielleicht wirklich nur so am rande aber
natürlich auch auf der teile also ich weiß jetzt nicht was das ist es geht
die ganze 這
also in diesem fall machen wir mal das die meine sql geschichte also das kenne
ich das habe ich auch schon mal gehört und ich bin verraten dass du mein sql
ne, ne, ne, Oracle, ja, bloß
SAP, igitt, es wird ja immer eklig
wir müssen das mal kurz, wir müssen das mal kurz
ein bisschen, ah ne, da sind jetzt
alle, bisschen reinzoomen
kann man da, ok
und jetzt Fullscreen vielleicht
ok, jetzt sieht man ein bisschen was
ah, oder auch nicht, Moment, jetzt ist Fullscreen
aber man kann nicht mehr scrollen
Alter, was ne Kackseite, man
ok, doch, Gamepad, danke für den Sub
also
Canva
MySQL, Canva
sagt mir nix, kann ich auch nicht mal lesen
kann ich auch nicht lesen
das kenn ich
das hab ich auch schon mal
irgendwo gesehen, SQL-Server, ok
siehst du, also davon kenn ich ganze drei Sachen
Cloud Events
sagt mir was, Nuts sagt mir auch was
das hab ich, ja, aber
genau, das hab ich auch schon mal gesehen
ansonsten
von dem restlichen Kram, das
kenn ich auch
ansonsten von dem restlichen Kram
keine Ahnung
Helm kennt jeder, der ein bisschen was mit Kubernetes
schon gemacht hat, das dürfte somit
eines der bekanntesten Sachen sein
das ist zum
installieren von Anwendungen
also sprich, es sind Kubernetes-Manifests
halt vorbereitet
fix und fertig, dass man eine Anwendung
zum Laufen kriegt
Backstage hab ich auch schon mal gehört, Buildpacks
kenn ich, Cubela sagt mir auch was, Cubirt
kenn ich auch, das ist um KVM-Sachen
in Kubernetes laufen zu lassen, falls man
wirklich VMs haben möchte
Operator-Framework hab ich auch schon mal gehört
das kommt mir auch bekannt vor
Kaniko kenn ich auch
das ist irgendwas, das ist irgendwas zum
Container-Builden
ohne
Root-Berechtigung, irgendwas komisches
Kubernetes-Build, Container-Build
in Kubernetes oder sowas
kenn ich hier alles nicht, Packer kenn ich noch
Tanker hab ich auch schon mal gehört, das ist irgendein
irgendein YAML-Dialekt glaub ich
Conveyor hab ich schon mal gehört
Raft auch
ist das
Docker-Compose, ja, Docker-Compose kennen wir auch
GVM, also sprich
man kennt ja nicht mal
alles davon, aber
es ist auf jeden Fall wichtig, dass man bei
vielen dieser Kästchen zumindest
ein bisschen
schon mal was von gehört hat
ich will jetzt, ich geh jetzt nicht alles durch
das dauert drei Stunden
ja die Logos sind teilweise richtig pepega
hier Rook, das ist glaube ich irgendein
File-System Zeug
hier steht ja auch hier unter Storage
also es ist nie verkehrt sich aus diesen ganzen Kästchen
so ein bisschen, gerade hier
gerade hier was Proxy und sowas angeht, ja
Nginx ist mit wahrscheinlich der bekannteste
Envoy ist halt oben, weil es ein Cloud Native Projekt ist
und
die coolen Leute
das wahrscheinlich benutzen
aber die meisten benutzen tatsächlich eher Nginx
Nginx ist halt so mit
mit das Default, der Default-Ingress, der Default-Proxy
für
Kubernetes, das liegt auch daran
weil der offizielle, das offizielle Ingress
Modul
von Kubernetes selbst eben auf Nginx basiert
und ich kann es ja nicht oft genug sagen
man darf Nginx Ingress nicht mit Nginx Ingress
äh nein, man darf Ingress Nginx nicht mit Nginx Ingress verwechseln
weil das eine ist der offizielle Kubernetes Ingress
vom Kubernetes Projekt
der auf Nginx basiert
und das andere ist der offizielle Nginx
vom Nginx Projekt für Kubernetes
alles klar?
so und das hier ist tatsächlich was, was die letzten
in letzter Zeit stark im kommen ist
Service Mesh
hauptsächlich für MTLS, dass Container auch untereinander
verschlüsselt reden können
aber es gibt noch viele weitere nice Sachen
und LinkAD ist mit Abstand, zumindest das, was ich mir angeguckt habe bisher
mit Abstand ist einfachds und Istio ist das komplizierteste wo keiner durchblickt
Istio gibt es beispielsweise bei Google in der Cloud managed
da heißt es dann glaube ich
oh wie heißt das?
An для
Anteos, Antheos oder sowas
das ist quasi ein Istio gemanagt von Google
nicht Tozz, ne
also ihr seht es ist
ja und wir wollen refersiert
und wir wollen auch gar nicht in das Thema Monitoring Logins zu sprechen sein,
Log-Analyse, Performance-Metrics und irgendwelche Statistiken gehen,
da gibt es noch mal tausend verschiedene andere Sachen.
Also ihr seht, das ist das, wo auch ein Großteil der Komplexität
so im Clown- und vor allem im Kubernetes-Umfeld herkommt,
weil Kubernetes selbst nur die halbe Miete ist.
Die 30 Milliarden Sachen drumherum, über die man so grob
zumindest mal was gehört haben sollte aus verschiedenen Bereichen,
die machen es halt richtig kompliziert.
Aber ich wollte mir die GitHub-Trends für die Woche angucken.
In meiner Ausbildung starte ich gerade in die Virtualisierung rein.
Wir Azubis haben jetzt einen eigenen Host.
Du meinst einen eigenen ESX, so eine eigene, alle ausgemusterte Kiste,
wo ihr euch wahrscheinlich ESX oder was benutzt ihr?
Also wir hatten damals den Azubi-Cluster beim Provider,
wo wir uns austoben konnten, wo wir mit alter Hardware auch üben konnten,
so nach dem Motto, okay, Cluster-Noise.
Haut fällt aus, wir tauschen mal aus und sowas.
Da hatten wir aus alter Hardware einen ESX-Cluster.
Und ich gehe mal davon aus, also das war noch vor Zeiten,
bevor es glaube ich ESX-I gab, ich gehe mal davon aus,
wir haben eine offizielle VMware-Installation gemacht,
ohne VMware-Lizenzgebühren damals dafür zu bezahlen.
Da haben die es aber eh nicht so ernst genommen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das Lizenzmodell von VMware damals gewesen ist.
Kannst du mal erklären, wie PAM unter Linux funktioniert?
Nee.
Niemand, der das richtig versteht.
Also eine Datei, die du dir merken musst, wenn es um Login und Authentifizierung unter Linux geht,
ist NSSwitchConf, weil da steht drinnen,
in welcher Reihenfolge verschiedene Authentifizierungs-Provider abgefragt werden.
Und das ist da, wo du meistens auch Sachen umstellen musst,
wenn du anderes Verhalten als Default haben willst.
Da kannst du zum Beispiel die Reihenfolge reinschreiben
und irgendwo, wenn du LDAP-Anmeldung machen willst.
Ach, im Moment nicht NSSwitch.
Was erzähle ich denn?
NSSwitch ist für...
Blödsinn, NSSwitch ist nicht für...
Ah!
NSSwitch ist für Namensauflösung.
Nee, nee, das ist für beides.
Jetzt bin ich...
Guck mal, siehst du mal.
Niemand, wo wir mal wieder unterstreichen können,
das versteht niemand.
Niemand versteht das.
Das ist für Namensauflösung und für Passwort-Authentifizierung.
Alles klar.
Da kann man nämlich reinschreiben,
in welcher Reihenfolge was passieren soll.
Und wenn man zum Beispiel LDAP-Anmeldung machen will,
dann muss man so gedönst dann eintragen in seine NSSwitchConf.
Aber wie gesagt, verstehen tut es keiner so wirklich.
Man copy-pasted Stack-Overflow-Sachen, bis es funktioniert.
Okay.
Also, was...
Was trendet denn diese Woche auf Shithub?
Coding-Interview-University.
Aha.
Cuban.
Ah, AI.
China-Chinesen-AI.
Gitness.
Ist das irgendwie ein weiterer GitHub-Klon?
Hören wir uns mal an.
Okay.
Fancy-Webseite schon mal.
Fancy-Webseite.
Mit Animations und allem.
Fast schon ein bisschen viel.
Aber hier...
Also, auf der Webseite hat sich der Webdesigner auf jeden Fall ausgetobt.
Oder was denkt ihr?
Das ist ja fast schon Apple-Style, die Webseite.
Also, da hat er sich echt ausgelassen drauf.
Es wäre natürlich cool,
so ein Screenshot vom Interface zu sehen,
was es eigentlich ist.
Ich habe immer noch keine Ahnung, was es ist.
Ist es irgendeine CI-Plattform oder so?
Was ist das überhaupt?
Open-Source-Code-Hosting- und Pipeline-Engine.
Aber warum?
Wisst ihr, manchmal fände ich es nice bei Projekten,
wenn einfach am Anfang dastehen würde.
Das ist es und deswegen sollte man es verwenden.
Weil das verstehe ich jetzt an der Stelle nicht.
Weil ich weiß echt nicht, was es mir bringen soll.
Aber es trendet.
Es muss gut sein mit 30.000 Sternen.
AI.
JavaScript ist am Trenden.
Warum trendet JavaScript?
Ja, Use-Case-Erklärung.
Genau sowas wäre nice.
Warum trendet JavaScript?
Gab es da irgendwas Neues?
Irgendwie... Ja, doch.
Erst 2023 gab es doch jetzt, oder?
Oder ist das schon eine Weile raus?
In GitHub ist eine kompakte Beschreibung.
Open-Source-Conti... Ja.
Ja, aber deswegen verstehe ich immer noch nicht,
warum ich es verwenden soll.
Ich kann einfach GitHub mit GitHub-Actions verwenden.
Dann habe ich eine Open-Source-Developer-Plattform
mit Continuous Integration und...
Naja, nicht wirklich.
Also, je nachdem, wie ich von GitHub-Actions
darauf zugreifen will, ist es mit Continuous Delivery
von GitHub-Actions,
je nachdem, wie man das gemacht hat,
wann das geht.
Letztendlich kannst du dich ja auch per SSH
und Repo-Secrets und so einloggen und anstoßen.
Aber Continuous Integration ist auf jeden Fall
eher die Stärke von GitHub-Actions
als Continuous Delivery.
Aber es ist natürlich sinnvoll, zum Beispiel
sein Container-Image zu bauen
in GitHub-Actions und das in die Registry zu pushen.
Und das dann anderweitig zu machen.
Und das dann anderweitig auszurollen.
Man könnte ja sagen, okay, das Container-Image
veröffentlichen ist schon Delivery.
Stimmt, Geschmackssache, wie man das
wie, wo klassifizieren wird.
Aber warum soll ich einfach GitHub-Actions verwenden?
Also, aktuell verstehe ich es noch nicht.
Und ich finde es auch ein bisschen doof, dass es...
Also, wisst ihr, das Beste ist immer,
bei Projekten, deswegen habe ich das
bei meinen auch so gemacht,
ein Screenshot.
Immer ein Screenshot rein.
Ja, also...
GitHub-Wobblords.
Deswegen habe ich bei allen Sachen, wo ich mir denke,
ey, das könnte vielleicht irgendjemand interessieren,
habe ich
ein Screenshot drinne.
Ja, hier ist ein Screenshot drinne,
wie das dann im Endeffekt das
Dashboard aussieht, das Ganze,
wie die Settings aussehen.
Hier ist ein, ist glaube ich sogar
ein, nee, kein GIF, ist ein Screenshot drinne
vom CLI-Workflow,
wie man das, wie man das
aufbaut, was hier ist mit dem...
Nice Emoji Fighter, read me.
Ja, hier ist, hier ist,
hier ist ein Bild drinne,
hier ist ein Bild drinne von der,
wo ich mal versucht habe,
so Versandtracker zu bauen.
Und sogar hier
vom EPG-Champ ist ein Bild drinne.
Also insofern,
ich finde, Screenshots ist immer
das Beste, was man machen kann.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
JavaScript-Rendels.
Was ist denn los heute?
Wieder Corona am Start.
Wartet mal.
Fuck.
Ich kann mich jetzt ja auch nicht muten.
Normalerweise kann ich mich muten, aber ich habe ja
mein Mikrofon direkt hier dran gestöpselt.
Kann nämlich nicht mal mehr muten, wenn ich husten muss.
Was soll ich...
Fitness.
Nicht Fitness.
Nein!
Ich will nach Fitness suchen.
Ja, da sieht man nicht wirklich was, oder?
Ist das, ist das
quasi ein
CI-CD-Ding?
Im Prinzip
ein modernerer Jenkins
oder sowas zum Selbsthosten.
So, ähm...
Realtime-Voice-Cloning
Pro-Painter, AI, interessiert mich
jetzt nicht. Xenminer.
Klingt jetzt nicht nach AI,
klingt aber ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen nach
Kryptogramm, das ignorieren wir auch mal.
Ähm, AI?
AI?
Kein AI?
Es ist einfach irgendwas...
Warum trendet irgendein Repo mit...
Ah,
okay, das sind Beispiele für
wie man mit...
wie man mit HTML coole Sachen machen kann.
Ja, das ist doch gerade einmal so verkehrt.
Oh, ne.
Ist das ein eigenes, ist das wieder ein neues UI-Framework?
Ne. What the fuck?
Was, was bin ich sehend?
Ne, das ist eine
Plattform, die...
Wo man, wo man...
Kurse, Kurse machen kann
für Webdesign oder so, okay.
Ähm, AI ignorieren wir mal.
Alter.
Reprogramming-Books.
Okay, nice. Also, wisst ihr, wisst ihr Leute,
wenn ich das sehe,
ihr kennt ja das beste GitHub-Repo ever, oder?
Ja.
Anime Girls
Holding Programming.
Nicht Pregnancy-Test.
Programming-Books.
So, C++.
Ich hab keine Ahnung,
warum das überhaupt ein Repo ist.
Ja. Aber das hat einfach
17.000 Sterne.
Arzi, dankeschön für den Sub.
Warum auch immer das ein Ding auf GitHub ist,
aber 17.000 Leuten scheint es zu gefallen.
So, was haben wir
sonst noch hier? LocalStack.
AWS-Zeug.
Das neue Windows-Terminal.
Ja, 90.000 Sterne.
90.000 Sterne
für das neue Windows-Terminal.
Da seht ihr mal, wie verzweifelt
Windows-User sind,
dass die einem
seit Jahrzehnten
endlich mal halbwegs
brauchbarem Terminal
einfach 90.000 Sterne geben.
Da seht ihr mal,
wie beschissen das alte Windows-Terminal
gewesen ist. Und das war auch beschissen.
Also, das ist, glaube ich, so ziemlich der
geilste Terminal-Shit,
den es so gibt.
Also, ich meine das hier.
Moment.
Das ist schon das Neue.
Wie macht man denn das Alte?
Ist das Alte überhaupt noch unter Windows?
Das ist gar nicht mehr da.
Wie startet man
das alte Terminal?
Alter, es ist ja schlimm, ey.
Wahrscheinlich kann man das Alte gar nicht.
Das Alte gibt es nicht mehr.
Seht ihr mal, wie verzweifelt die Leute
gewesen sind, ey. Also,
das neue Windows-Terminal, das hier,
das kann man ja tatsächlich halbwegs benutzen.
Es ist natürlich weit davon entfernt,
ein ordentliches Terminal zu sein.
Ja.
Ein ordentliches Terminal ist zum Beispiel
sowas hier.
Ja, mal kurz starten.
Warum benutzen wir nicht gleich die PowerShell?
Das eine hat doch mit dem anderen nichts zu tun.
Das eine ist das Terminal, das andere ist die Shell.
Das eine hat mit dem anderen
gar nichts zu tun.
So, das hier ist zum Beispiel ein ordentliches Terminal.
Das hier ist das Terminal
und da drinnen
läuft eine Shell da drinnen.
Kann aber auch eine andere Shell laufen.
Eigentlich egal.
So, das ist ein ordentliches Terminal.
Das hier ist auch ein brauchbares Terminal.
Aber das alte CMD-Terminal hier,
Windows-Terminal
CMD, das Alte, falls sich da
jemand nicht mehr
daran erinnern kann, ich meine
jetzt
Das hier meine ich, ja.
Schrecklich.
Und die Leute sind so verzweifelt, dass
die 90.000 Sterne für das neue Terminal
raushauen, wenn es das erste halbwegs
brauchbare ist seit Jahrzehnten.
So, was haben wir als nächstes?
Ok, AI?
Ne.
Open Core Legacy Patcher.
Was machen die?
Experience macOS just like before.
Ähm.
Ach, das ist für alte Macs.
Ok.
Power Toys.
Ok, dem kann man mal einen Stern geben.
Da sind ein paar ganz praktische Sachen drin.
Zum Beispiel das Shortcut-Tool.
Wagtail.
Agents.
AI-Zeug.
Ich brauch unbedingt meinen Mute-Knopf,
dass ich euch nicht immer ins Ohr husten muss.
Ich hab hier übelst trockenen Hals gerade.
Web Framework für Go.
Und irgendwelche PDF-Geschichten.
Ja gut, ja gut.
Nicht so spannend.
Ach Moment, das war Trending
this week.
Lass mal grad gucken, was in der .NET-Welt so trendet.
Ich trink schon die ganze Zeit.
Aber ich hab super trockenen Hals.
Ich hab mir ja für die Zeit,
müsste ich mal wieder verwenden,
für Zeiten, in denen ich viel streame,
letzten paar Wochen hab ich weniger gestreamt,
aber es gab ja mal Zeiten,
da war ich jeden Tag abends on.
Ich hab mir damals
so ein Copium-Ding gekauft.
Inhaliergerät.
So ein Teil hab ich mir damals gekauft.
Dass mein Hals nicht so trocken ist,
wenn ich zu viel laber und zu viel streame.
Siehst du mal hier,
in was für Kosten ich mich wieder
gestürzt hab für euch.
Copium-Time.
Irgendwie so was.
Hat's was gebracht?
Ja.
Kommst dir zwar vor,
als hättest du sonst was für eine Krankheit,
weil du das regelmäßig brauchst,
aber es ist, wenn du viel laberst
und was man halt macht,
ich laber ja quasi dann 2-3 Stunden durchgängig
und wenn du das jeden Tag machst,
ich mein, gibt's Streamer, die machen 8 Stunden am Tag,
aber die spielen dann halt auch und labern vielleicht nicht
komplett durchgängig.
Wenn du jeden Tag 3 Stunden schwätzt,
so sagen wir mal,
das ist jetzt auch ein bisschen
nicht super, ich hänge in der Ecke
und krieg kaum ein Wort raus, entspannt.
Es hat wirklich was gebracht.
Also in Zeiten, wo ich jeden Tag oder jeden zweiten Tag
paar Stunden online war,
hat es richtig was gebracht für den Hals.
Ich hab bei weitem nicht mehr so einen trockenen
und gereizten Hals.
Letztendlich macht man da einfach nur ein bisschen Salz,
Salzlösung rein,
so Salzwasser
und
setzt sich dann da 6-7 Minuten hin.
Aber das bringt wirklich was.
Ich würde es jedem empfehlen,
der einen trockenen Hals hat.
Also nicht das, irgend so ein Ding in der Richtung.
Ich hab das gekauft, weil ich glaube ich bei Amazon
damals irgendwo empfohlen bekommen hab
oder vielleicht sogar bei irgendeinem Primeday
oder so, ich weiß nicht.
Und dann hab ich gesagt, hier, komm, mal ausprobieren.
Das hat wirklich was gebracht.
Muss natürlich auch passen, Salzlösung.
Mark Jojo, dankeschön für den Sub.
So, was trendet denn in der .NET Welt?
Power Toys.
Ja, ok, hatten wir schon. Maui.
Maui trendet, verstehe ich nicht. Maui ist Shit.
Und ich warte eigentlich nur darauf,
dass Microsoft
eine Meldung veröffentlicht,
dass das Projekt eingestellt wird.
Vielleicht nicht dieses Jahr, vielleicht nicht nächstes Jahr,
aber dann. Ich glaube nicht, dass Maui
lange
da bleiben wird.
Was hältst du von einem KI-Stream, um alle Sterne
auf GitHub einzusammeln?
Wie, wie, wie, hä?
Wie jetzt? Du meinst, ich soll
ein KI-Projekt veröffentlichen,
damit ich mehr Likes kriege auf GitHub, oder?
PowerShell trendet, ok.
ASP.NET Core
trendet.
Ich finde,
echt, ich finde das echt underrated.
Ich meine, man kann sagen,
32.000 GitHub-Sterne ist, also in der .NET Welt
ist es definitiv nicht underrated, aber so
in der, so in der Public,
so in der öffentlichen Meinung
bei IT-Leuten finde ich
das ASP.NET Core etwas underrated.
Für meinen Geschmack,
wenn man jetzt nicht einen speziellen
Grund hat, ein anderes Backend-Framework
zu nehmen, so nach dem Motto, ah, ich möchte
hier SvelteKit Full-Stack
oder was auch immer machen, ist
ASP.NET Core aus
meiner Meinung nach
das angenehmste Framework
für Backend,
Web-Backend, was es gibt.
Das hat, das hat
eine super Kombination aus Features,
eine super angenehme
Sprache, mit der man das programmieren kann,
Performance,
das ist rundum einfach, finde ich,
so defaultmäßig eine richtig gute Wahl,
wenn man, wenn man sonst keine
driftigen Gründe für andere
Web-Backend-Technologien
hat.
Deswegen mache ich auch die meisten Backend-Sachen
mit ASP.NET.
Ja, leider ist das Ansehen natürlich ein bisschen nicht so
hoch, weil es von, weil Microsoft
in,
ja, vor längerer
Zeit viel Scheiße gebaut hat
und immer noch teilweise Scheiße baut,
darf man ja nicht vergessen, und,
und eines der Hauptprobleme,
wieso ist da OSU, weil es ein
C-Shop-Programm ist,
OSU ist
für alle unsere
Musikfans.
Das größte Problem bei
Microsoft und ihren Open-Source-Projekten
ist die Benahmung.
ASP.NET Core,
der Name ist
auf so vielen Ebenen dumm.
Erstens hat ASP.NET
Core mit ASP.NET nichts zu tun,
was viele Leute noch kennen, und
was für viele ein super,
ja, altertümliches
Web-Framework ist.
Hat nichts miteinander zu tun, außer dem Namen.
Es heißt Core, weil es eine
Neuentwicklung war für .NET Core.
Das Problem ist, dass Microsoft
.NET Core mittlerweile umbenannt hat
in .NET. Also,
es ist,
die Microsoft-Benahmung ist einfach so
extrem pepega, was bei ihren,
was ihre Produkte angeht,
das, das verstehe ich nicht. Die hätten das
komplett anders nennen sollen. Ja, ich gette,
dass sie das erstmal ASP.NET nennen wollten,
Core so als neues
ASP.NET.
Die hätten das, die hätten das
irgendwie, irgendwie anders.
Sowas wie Blazor. Blazor finde ich okay.
Das ist, ja, das ist ein Witz
aus Razor Pages und Blazor
und WebAssembly. Aber ich finde,
ich finde Blazor ist ein guter Name.
Das ist nichts, was es schon gab.
Das ist was Neues. Das ist ein Name, der ist
einprägsam. Und ASP.NET
Core, ey, das ist einfach wir.
Ja, das, das brauchen, das brauchen griffigen,
ingriffigen Namen.
Payday 3 Server Emulation.
Das ist ja lustig. Das gibt es,
weil die Payday 3 Server so viel abkacken, oder
wie? Gibt es eine
moderne Form von Active Server Pages?
Ich hoffe ja nicht. Du meinst,
du meinst Webforms und sowas, gell?
Ne, du kannst das immer noch
verwenden. Also,
was du, was du mit ASP.NET
Core machen kannst, ist klassisches
MVC mit Server-Side-Rendering
und Razor Pages.
Das funktioniert.
Ich persönlich muss halt sagen,
ich benutze den Razor
Pages Teil von ASP.NET Core
nie. Ich mache eigentlich nur Web-API
Projekte. Und mein
Frontend dann mit
mit Svelte und SvelteKit.
Schlimmer in Hals
gerade. Aber ich bin ja auch kein
hauptsächlicher Frontend-Entwickler.
So, hier wird Windows optimist
mit 8000 Sternen. Avalonia.
Siehste, sehen wir mal.
Avalonia ist ein toller Produktname
oder ein toller Projektname im Vergleich
zu ASP.NET Core. Kann man sich gut merken.
Und
ja, ist
griffig und verbindet man auch
irgendwas Gutes. Übrigens wisst ihr, warum
das ganze Avalonia heißt?
Es ist übrigens meine Interpretation
des Ganzen. Ich weiß nicht, ob die das offiziell
gesagt haben.
Avalonia ist ja ein UI-Framework
im Gegensatz zu Maui.
Wo haben wir es?
Hier. Im Gegensatz zu Maui.
Was seine UIs
noch selber zeichnet.
Was, finde ich, der deutlich bessere Ansatz ist.
Und dementsprechend auch komplett
Cross-Plattform. Zum Beispiel läuft es auch unter
Linux und solchen Geschichten.
So, und
es basiert ja auf
ähnlicher Technologie. Also es ist im Prinzip
so ein XML-UI-Beschreibungsdialekt.
Es heißt Avalonia,
weil ich glaube,
dass WPF
quasi das
das Vorbild
was
das UI-Design anging.
Dies glaube ich mal
Project Avalon
bei Microsoft ursprünglich.
Und deswegen haben die das
glaube ich Avalonia genannt. Übrigens
ich fände, es wäre für Microsoft
viel cooler gewesen, sie hätten das Avalon
genannt, anstatt
Windows Presentation
Foundation. Ich meine,
was findet ihr schöner und griffiger
als Produktname? Avalonia?
Oder Windows Presentation Foundation?
Microsoft
hat aber einen Hang dazu
Zungenbrecher zu machen.
Ich erinnere euch nur mal an Kinect.
Kinect hieß Project Natal.
Richtig schöner,
griffiger, kurzer, prägnanter
Name, den man sich bis heute
merken kann. Und
als es rausgekommen ist, hieß es dann Kinect.
Keiner konnte es richtig aussprechen.
Ja, und es kommt noch dazu,
das Avalonia. Wir haben es ja sogar
hier im Stream benutzt.
Ich fand das ganze Jammelzeug immer noch nicht geil,
aber
wenigstens ist das, was rauskommt,
ganz brauchbar.
Ist Project Dolphin nicht der
Gamecube Emulator?
Ist das nicht der Gamecube Emulator?
Okay, alles klar.
So, also
lasst mal auf YouTube gucken. Wir wollen uns
das neue, wir wollen uns das hier zum Raspberry Pi
angucken.
Raspberry Pi 5. Was kostet
der denn aktuell? Kann man den überhaupt schon kaufen?
Hat der jetzt einen Lüfter?
Introducing
Raspberry Pi 5.
Berry Base.
Raspberry...
Vorverkauf ab dem 23.10.
Okay, Leute. Der wird
direkt pre-ordert.
Yeah.
Ne, also lasst mal kurz checken,
was da so
alles...
Leute, meine Tabs. Ich habe zu viele Tabs offen.
Ne, das weiß ich noch nicht.
Ich sehe es jetzt zum ersten Mal.
Also 60 Dollar für die
vier...
Er ist ein bisschen teurer geworden.
Aber es wurden
anscheinend
die 2Gig-Variante wurde
anscheinend abgeschafft.
Ist okay.
Ich fände es nicht schlecht, wenn es noch eine 2Gig-Variante
gäbe, weil 2Gig reichen für sehr viele
Anwendungen auch komplett aus.
Okay, was
ist denn jetzt da drinnen?
2,4 Gigahertz
Quad-Core.
Ah, es ist kein... Was war das vorher?
Ein A51 oder sowas, gell?
Das ist eine deutlich neuere CPU.
Ne, das ist nicht so gedacht.
Es gibt... Ah, 4K
60 FPS
H265
Decoder.
Dual Output.
Ja, brauche ich so gut wie nie.
Den Part davon brauche ich auch nicht.
So gut wie nie.
Mich würde der Hardware Encoder
tatsächlich interessieren, was es da Neues gibt.
Dual Band WiFi.
Okay, es ist AC.
Aber heißt auch
5 Gigahertz, ne?
Sehe ich doch richtig, oder?
Chatgear.
5 Gigahertz, ne?
War das auch schon...
Ja.
Also 2,4 und 5.
Dual Band.
So.
Bluetooth 5.
Bluetooth Low Energy.
Ja, welcher Standard wäre noch ganz interessant?
High Speed Micro SD-Card Interface.
Was ist
SDR 104 Mode?
Was für... Wahrscheinlich
was für Micro SD-Karten, Flash,
Speicher, was auch immer.
2x USB 3.0 Ports.
Supporting SIM.
Okay, das ist eine ganze Ecke.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Noch nicht mal.
Leute, ihr wisst, wenn ein Standard scheiße ist.
Noch nicht mal der Hersteller nennt das richtig.
Das sind keine USB 3.0 Ports.
Ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen.
Die korrekte Bezeichnung
Die korrekte Bezeichnung ist
USB 3.2 Gen 1x1
Man kann nicht einfach USB 3.0
Man kann nicht einfach USB 3.0 sagen.
Das USB Forum hat retroaktiv
ihren Scheiß umbenannt.
Man muss korrekt sein.
Und um die Sache noch besser zu machen,
demnächst haben wir USB 4V2
Demnächst haben wir USB 4V2
Es ist dumm.
Ich war fast verr kellst ..."
Was?
Jetzt ist ernst gemeinte Frage...
Was hat die davon abgehalten
It ist einfach
USB 4.0 und 4.1
USB 4.1 und 4.1
zu nennen und die Namen einfach gleich zu lassen?
Oder sie hätten es USB 5.0 nennen sollen?
Hätten es USB 5.0
Letztendlich juckt es doch keinen.
Es braucht irgendeinen griffigen Namen.
Aber das ist halt mal richtig, richtig, richtig hängen geblieben.
Dämlich, Alter.
USB 3.2 Gen 1x1.
Wisst ihr...
Übrigens, Chat, wenn ihr es nicht wisst, ja.
Nur mal so, wie das für Leute, die sich das nicht durchgelesen haben, wirkt.
Was meint ihr, wofür dieses 2x2 und 2x1 und 1x1 steht?
Was denkt ihr?
Ihr müsst euch da reinversetzen, das ist was, was auf einer Packung draufsteht.
Was denkt ihr, was das bedeutet?
So als jemand, der keine...
Gigabit, nee, ist falsch.
Sind das die Adern?
Ja, korrekt.
Das sind die Daten...
Die Daten...
Die Kupferdrähte zur Datenübertragung.
Warum man das reinschreibt, verstehe ich nicht.
Niemand, der sich ein USB-Kabel kauft, also niemand der normalen Leute, die technisch da nicht so interessiert sind,
die juckt es einen kompletten Scheiß.
Gar nicht. Null juckt das die.
Wie viel Kupferleitung in ihrem USB-Kabel drin sind für die Datenübertragung.
Die Leute juckt, wie schnell das Daten übertragen kann, dass das schön kompatibel funktioniert.
Aber wie viel Daten...
Das geht denen so am Arsch vorbei, das juckt überhaupt nicht.
Ah ja, also das bedeutet in dem Fall wirklich Generation 1.
Ja, also eine Generation 1, 3.2 Datenleitung, einfach.
Und hier ist es eine Generation 2 mal 2.
Leute, wir. Komplett pepega wir.
So, dann haben wir USB 2.0 Ports.
Nice.
Formfaktor.
Ist immer noch der gleiche.
Wir haben Gigabit-Ethernet.
Oh, schade.
Schade, dass es keinen 2.5G-Ethernet gibt.
PoE-Support.
Das gab es doch die ganze Zeit schon, oder?
Mit einem Head.
Neues...
Nö, die Kameramodule sind auch noch...
Nee.
Chatge.
Was ist denn das da?
Ich dachte...
Das hier sind die Kameras.
Und was ist das?
PCI 2x...
Okay.
Oh, cool.
Man kann jetzt PCI-Express anschließen.
Wahrscheinlich ist das da unten PCI-Express.
Da braucht man irgendwie so ein Flachbandkabel.
Auf einen PCI-Express-Slot.
Okay, das finde ich cool.
Das finde ich cool.
Aber es ist nur PCI-Express einfach.
Also PCI-Express 2.0 einfach.
Ähm, gucken wir mal.
Das ist nicht sonderlich schnell.
Hier.
Ja, das ist ein halbes Gigabit.
Es ist wirklich nicht die Welt.
Was da drüber geht.
Also, man sollte vielleicht eher keine...
Okay, man könnte eine Grafikkarte anschließen zum Main.
Falls irgendjemand sowas dafür machen möchte.
Was wahrscheinlich aber preis-leistungsmäßig sich null lohnt.
Ich meine, es ist trotzdem gut, dass es das gibt.
Denn, zum Beispiel möchte man vielleicht tatsächlich eine 10-Gigabit-Netzwerkkarte dran machen.
Die dann zwar nicht 10-Gigabit kann, aber den SFP-Plus-Anschluss hat.
Falls man Raspberry Pi braucht mit einem SFP-Plus-Anschluss.
Also, es kann durchaus Sinn machen.
Oder wenn man, oder wenn man ja mal ein bisschen, wobei schnelleren Storage kriegt man damit auch hin.
Besser über USB.
Also, ich bin auch ein bisschen...
Eine Capture-Karte vielleicht.
Eine Capture-Karte.
Oder so.
Ich bin auch ein bisschen unschlüssig, wofür man das genau braucht.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall sehr nice, dass es ein PCI-Express-Interface jetzt gibt.
Standard-GPIO-Header.
So.
Also, es hat sich ja in der Summe jetzt nicht allzu viel getan.
Das Ding sieht auch nahezu 1 zu 1 noch aus wie der 4er.
Bisschen, bisschen anders hier mit dem Ding unten.
Und der...
Das ist die Grafikkarte hier, ne?
Das ist die CPU, das ist die Grafikkarte.
Oder umgedreht?
Ich glaube...
So ist das.
Nun gut.
Ja, New Chipset ist wahrscheinlich wirklich wichtig, weil die waren ja schon komplett am Limit.
Beim alten.
Okay, dann schauen wir uns mal das Video dazu an.
Schauen wir uns mal das Video dazu an.
Guck mal hier.
Das ist der Raspberry Pi 5.
Wir haben vorab ein Testexemplar bekommen und den neuen Raspberry schon mal durch ein paar Benchmarks gejagt.
Guck mal hier.
Das ist der Raspberry Pi 5.
Wir haben vorab ein Testexemplar bekommen und den neuen Raspberry schon mal durch ein paar Benchmarks gejagt.
Okay.
Der Raspberry Pi 5 ist wie der Raspberry Pi 4.
Also, ich habe keine Ahnung von den Benchmark-Ergebnissen.
Ich würde aber davon ausgehen, dass sie eine ganze Ecke besser sind.
Neuer Chipsatz und vor allem deutlich modernere CPU.
Der Chipsatz ist nicht so relevant.
Das ist eher, dass es halt überhaupt funktioniert.
Eine deutlich modernere CPU.
Ich persönlich kenne mich mit ARM so leistungswert nicht sonderlich gut aus.
Aber ich würde mal sagen, so 30-40% schneller vielleicht.
Vielleicht liege ich auch komplett falsch und das ist viel mehr.
Aber ich bin mal gespannt.
Ein vollwertiger Rechner kostet um die 70 Euro und ist genauso klein, aber viel, viel besser.
Klar, schneller sowieso, könnt ihr euch denken.
Aber er hat auch jetzt erstmals einen PCI-Express-Anschluss, an dem man unter anderem SSDs hängen kann.
Aber ein paar Nachteile...
Ja gut, mit SSDs bist du natürlich mit 500 Mbit, macht keinen Sinn, wenn du allein schon USB hast, wo 5 Gigabit drüber geht.
... haben wir auch gefunden. Bleibt dran.
Düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt.
Leckerin, lieber Internet-Surfer, herzlich willkommen hierbei.
Düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt.
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von...
NordVPN. Nein.
... ich weiß nicht, ob ihr...
Okay, na komm, wir sind mal so nett.
... man hascht es und ernährt sich primär von Fastfood.
Ich habe übrigens... Leute, ich habe eine Sponsoring-Anfrage bekommen von HelloFresh.
Und wisst ihr was Teil dieses Sponsorings wäre?
Ein monatlicher Essensgutscheine.
Wo ich dann selbst helfe.
HelloFresh ausprobieren kann
und wenn ihr euch
HelloFresh bestellt
krieg ich Fettstonks
sogar
verhältnismäßig
sagen wir mal
annehmbare Konditionen
das Problem ist
Leute, nein ich muss kein FaceReveal
machen, das Problem ist
ich mach so wenig Videos
in letzter Zeit
ich komm ja aktuell vielleicht mal
auf ein Video im Monat
da lohnt sich irgendwelche
Sponsoring Sachen gar nicht
richtig, ich mein kommt immer
ein bisschen drauf an was, aber
also, ja
YouTuberin hat letztens erst ein Video über
den Saftladen gemacht, würde ich nicht supporten, wieso
warum ist das ein Saftladen, also ich hab
von dem was ich bisher gesehen hab eigentlich
einen ganz guten Eindruck gehabt von HelloFresh
ich kenn auch einen bei mir auf der Arbeit
also auf der alten Arbeit, der hat
schon Monate lang
hatte der ein HelloFresh Abo
und war damit echt zufrieden
die verschicken auch Saft
Omega Juice
keine Ahnung ob die Saft verschicken
nein, nein, das haben wir noch nicht geguckt
haha, das ist ne gute Idee
ja, aber warum ist das denn jetzt ein Saftladen
erzählt mal
ich will mir das jetzt nicht komplett angucken
warum alle Influencer
fünfzehn
fünfzehn, warum
alle Influencer Werbung machen für HelloFresh
naja, weil es Geld gibt
weil es Kohle gibt, warum denn sonst
hundertzweitausend Abonnenten schon, warum ist das so?
Später sitze ich immer noch hier.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht später.
Kann mir irgendjemand TooLongDidn'tWatch
erklären, warum es ein Kackladen ist?
Na gut, gucken wir uns das Raspberry Pi
Video weiter.
Viel zu teuer und zu viel Verpackungsmüll.
Naja, zu teuer
ist es ja nicht,
wenn es die Leute machen.
Also ja, man kann natürlich sagen, hey, wenn man das selbst
kauft, dann ist das
alles viel billiger. Ja, das ist ungefähr
genauso, wie wenn ich mir beim Essen
gehen eine Flasche Wasser bestelle für 5
Euro. Die kriege ich im
Getränkemarkt für 30 Cent oder so.
Zu viel Verpackungsmüll,
okay, das lasse ich mir noch
irgendwie gefallen. Ist halt die Frage,
worauf die achten.
Achten die drauf, dass es...
Ich meine, wahrscheinlich
ist weniger Verpackungsmüll sogar noch teurer.
Ist immer schwer zu sagen.
ja, so aus dem Kontext.
Zu wenig Inhalt, okay, das ist
natürlich
ja, okay,
Verhältnis zu was? Zu wenig Inhalt.
Wäre mit regional
wahrscheinlich auch nicht wirklich... Okay, das finde ich
natürlich kacke, wenn irgendwas
erzählt wird, was nicht stimmt. Das ist natürlich
dann auch immer so an der Grenze, wo man sich fragt,
so, ist das erlaubt?
Du darfst den Leuten ja Scheiße
verkaufen.
Du darfst auch wahrscheinlich weglassen,
dass es Scheiße ist und es
anpreisen als irgendwas ganz Tolles.
Aber du darfst nicht sagen, du bekommst
Gold, obwohl es keins ist.
Max,
also vielleicht mache ich das, muss ich mal
gucken.
Wenn das taugt, ich probiere das mal aus. Die sollen mir so einen Gutschein,
die sollen mir einen Gutschein schicken, dann probiere ich das mal
eine Woche aus und dann...
Meine Katze würde jetzt
sagen, dann probiere ich das mal aus
und wenn das schmeckt, vielleicht mache ich das.
Meine Katze schmatzt übelst
beim Fressen, ist mir aufgefallen letztens.
Ich habe in der Küche gestanden
und hab da was
hingestellt und war dann irgendwie ein paar Meter weg
von und am Anfang
ich meine, ihr kennt das vielleicht,
am Anfang sind Katzen ja immer super, super vorsichtig,
aber ich habe die jetzt ja schon eine Weile
und die schmatzt rum, Alter.
Du denkst, du denkst wundert,
die frisst gerade irgendwie so
keine Ahnung, ein komplettes Hähnchen oder so.
Dabei sind es irgendwie nur zwei, drei
kleine Löffel irgendeinen Mousse
und die schmatzt da rum.
Und man denkt,
Chico, Alter,
man denkt, du frisst die Glasschüssel mit unten
drunter. So, aber Raspberry,
Pai, angucken.
Zu viel Kohlenhydrate und schlechte Fette,
aber vor allem fehlen Pflanzenstoffe,
Bakterienkulturen, Ballaststoffe.
Eine ausgewogene Ernährung und Sport
sind wichtig und dabei kann
AG1 unterstützen.
Da sind etliche Makro- und Mikronährstoffe drin,
alle sinnvoll aufeinander abgestimmt
und mit optimierter Bio-Verfügbarkeit.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich das haben will.
Ich habe AG1 mehrere Wochen lang ausprobiert
und muss...
Was zum Teufel ist Bio-Verfügbarkeit?
Ach so, ob man es aus Bio-Anbau bekommt.
... ist wirklich einfach,
zuzubereiten. Einfach einen Löffel Pulver
in die mitgelieferte Trinkflasche mit...
Er sagt absichtlich nicht, ob es schmeckt.
... Wasser schütteln, fertig.
Löst sich super aus und schmeckt gut.
Ein bisschen wie...
Sieht aus wie ein Smoothie, bloß in schlecht.
... wie Apfel mit Salat.
Erstaunlich unkünstlich und auch nicht unangenehm süß.
Wenn ihr das auch mal ausprobieren wollt,
auf drinkag1.com
...
... bekommt ihr bei Abschluss einer monatlichen
Mitgliedschaft einen kostenlosen Jahresvorrat
mit Vitamin D3 und K2 und
fünf kostenlose AG1-Travel-Packs
für unterwegs.
Soll ich euch auch mal was sagen?
Nicht irgendwie
super krass wissenschaftlich
fundiert, aber
ich gehe nicht davon aus,
dass irgendjemand Mangelernährung hat,
der ganz normal ist.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass wir
hier irgendwie in
in Armut leben
und
Tage nichts zu essen bekommen
und dann irgendwie nur irgendwas
Schlechtes. Wenn man ganz normal isst,
hat man wahrscheinlich keine
Mangelernährung.
Es mag einem vielleicht mal ein bisschen Vitamin D
fehlen, mal ein bisschen Vitamin Dings, aber
im Großen und Ganzen sind wir
wahrscheinlich alle ganz gut versorgt.
Oder meint ihr nicht?
... D3 und K2 und fünf
kostenlose AG1-Travel-Packs.
Wahrscheinlich könnte man sogar
jeden Tag
McDonalds und Pizza-Hut fressen
und das wäre halbwegs okay.
Außer, dass man
Massive-Pippo-Fett wird.
Aber ab und zu ein Salat ist vielleicht nicht verkehrt.
Ich denke mal, wenn man
wirklich das isst, worauf man
Bock hat
und bei mir ist es zumindest so,
ich esse halt auch durchaus gerne
mal Bratkartoffeln-Fettisch oder sowas,
aber auch ab und zu mal einen Salat
und das ist gut.
Ich habe mega Hunger in letzter Zeit, Leute.
Seitdem ich hier angefangen habe, mehr Sport zu machen,
also mit dem Rennen ging es noch, aber jetzt,
seitdem ich hier noch Fahrrad gefahren bin,
ich habe so übertrieben,
Hunger den ganzen Tag.
Das ist Wahnsinn.
AG1-Travel-Packs für unterwegs.
Wenn ihr zum ersten Mal bestellt,
gibt es außerdem eine Aufbewahrungsdose
und einen Shaker obendrauf.
Erbung Ende.
Ja, der Raspi 5, das war jetzt für uns
auch eine echte Überraschung,
dass der jetzt schon veröffentlicht wurde.
Denn der Raspi-Hauptentwickler Iben Abtin
hatte in Interviews bislang immer gesagt,
dass erst ab 2024
mit größeren Neuigkeiten zu rechnen ist.
Gut, weil irgendjemand mal irgendwas sagt,
kann man ja nicht so viel sagen.
Das ist ja auch so.
Aber nun also doch jetzt schon.
Also schon.
Der Raspi 4 ist nun auch über 4 Jahre alt.
Und ja, das Ding ist mir wirklich
ans Herz gewachsen.
Und dass der Raspi ein Herzensgerät von mir ist,
das sieht man ja deutlich an diesem Channel.
Über kein anderes Gadget haben wir mehr Videos gemacht.
Ja, außer 30 Milliarden AI-Videos.
Drei Raspis habe ich übrigens gerade am Laufen.
Man kann ja auch so viele tolle Sachen mit so machen.
Ich habe aktuell nur noch
ein paar Raspis.
Zwei Stück laufen.
Das heißt, die anderen liegen unused hier rum.
Ich habe einmal was für meinen 3D-Drucker.
Und einmal im Keller,
wo unter anderem ein
Automation FAT dran ist.
Es heißt P-HAT, aber ich finde FAT
die deutlich, deutlich bessere Aussprache davon.
Ein Automation FAT
dran ist, aber nicht so.
Einer, sondern Automation FAT Mini.
So ein Teil ist da dran.
Und das hat, wobei ich habe einen ohne Display.
Und da hat man zusätzlich noch die Möglichkeit,
beispielsweise ein Relay zu schalten über den Raspberry Pi.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie das Chat geht.
Wo sind die Elektronikers unter euch?
Wie nennt sich das, wenn das eine Input mit dem Output nicht potenzialfrei,
potent, das ist das Wort, was ich gesucht habe.
Ja, habe ich recht.
Potenzialfrei nennt sich das.
Kannst du ein potenzialfreies Relay schalten.
Dann kannst du verschiedene Geräte mit ansteuern.
Du hast Analog-Digital-Konverter und du kannst Binary-In-Outputs verwenden.
Ich habe beispielsweise hier habe ich
an diesem Analog-Digital-Konverter habe ich die meine Tür-Gegen-Sprechanlage dran,
um zu checken, ob es geklingelt hat.
Dann macht der Raspberry Pi auch noch die Steuerung für meine Heizung im Keller.
Und das sind, glaube ich, alle.
Ich hatte mal deutlich mehr.
Ich hatte noch mal zwei Stück im Wohnzimmer unten.
Einer davon war noch, als ich noch Unifi Access Points hatte, war für das Unifi
Unifi, für die Unifi Controller, so hieß das, für die Unifi Controller.
Und der andere war für die ganzen Kameras im Haus.
Aber das habe ich mittlerweile auch auf meine
HP Home Assistant Kiste mit drauf.
Und da hatte ich bestimmt, da hatte ich noch Zeros am Start.
Habe ich noch irgendwo einen Zero gerade?
Glaube auch nicht mehr.
Glaube, die sind alle
alle weg.
Glaube, es sind nur noch zwei Raspberry Pis übrig geblieben aktuell.
Dafür, dafür die ESP32 hängen noch ein paar rum.
Also ich habe nur noch zwei im Einsatz.
Und wenn ich nicht gerade irgendwas vergessen habe.
Ich meine, ich meine, zusätzlich habe ich hatte ich noch im Wohnzimmer.
Es war kein Raspberry Pi.
Das war ein.
Rock.
HC, HC2.
Rock Chip oder so, wie ist das Ding?
Odroid, Odroid HC, HC2.
Das ist zwar, das ist zwar kein Raspberry Pi.
Aber das ist auch so ein Single Board
Computer, ein Single Board Computer, wo man das Gehäuse sieht so krass hässlich aus,
wo man eine 2,5 Zoll Disc oder SSD anschließen konnte.
3,5 Zoll oder eine SSD anschließen konnte.
Hatte ich auch hatte ich auch im Einsatz für
zum Aufnehmen von Fernsehsachen.
Meine Mutter guckt halt gerne immer noch
Rosamunde Pilcher oder irgendeinen Blödsinn aufnehmen kann aus dem Fernsehen.
Das ist jetzt allerdings auch abgeschafft.
Ja, aktuell, ich glaube, wenn ich jetzt nicht ganz was vergessen habe, bin ich
down to zwei Raspberry Pis.
Also Spielkonsole bauen, ein Home Server mit zum Beispiel Pi-Hole und Plex,
eine Mars Rover Steuerung, also wirklich, das ist die Open Source Variante des Mars
Rovers von Plex zu Mars Rover und offiziell von der NASA.
Und die benutzt auch ein Raspi.
Vieles am Raspi ist besonders, unter anderem, dass viele der Platinen in Europa,
genauer in Wales hergestellt werden.
Was ja wirklich für Elektronik super ungewöhnlich ist.
Außerdem steckt hinter dem Raspi kein kommerzielles Unternehmen, sondern die
Raspberry Pi Foundation, eine gemeinnützige Stiftung, die Computerbildung für Kinder
und Jugendliche fördern will. Also ich finde es wirklich sympathisch alles.
Auch wenn der Ruf der Raspis in den letzten
Jahren etwas gelitten hat, weil die Dinger so schlecht lieferbar waren, dass man zum
Teil Mondpreise dafür bezahlen musste. Die Preise haben sich aber inzwischen wieder
einigermaßen normalisiert. Und ja, jetzt kommt der Raspi 5.
Den Europreis, den haben wir leider noch nicht.
Aber wir gehen davon aus, dass er in der
Version mit vier Gigabyte um die oder knapp über 70 Euro kosten wird.
Während es den Raspi 4 auch mit einem und
zwei Gigabyte gibt, gibt es den 5er vorerst nur mit vier und acht Gigabyte.
Laut Raspberry Pi Foundation sollte der braucht man also für viele Anwendungen
braucht man eigentlich gar keine vier und acht.
Zwei wäre nicht schlecht, vor allem wenn es den noch mal 15 Dollar billiger gäbe.
Sagen wir mal für 40 Dollar wäre doch nice.
Ich gehe auch davon aus, dass die Instant
ausverkauft sind. Ich werde mir auch direkt einkaufen.
Ein 5er Raspi 5 ab sofort bestellbar sein.
Mal sehen, ob das wirklich so ist.
Statt dem System on a Chip Broadcom BCM 2711 gibt es nun den BCM 2712.
Warum? Weil es geht.
Vorgänger vier Armkerne, die aber höher
getaktet sind und vor allem eine leistungsfähigere Architektur haben.
Cortex A6. Ich habe mir auch die Wifi Zero Variante zwei Stück Instant gekauft.
Die liegen jetzt hier rum.
Und brauche ich für nix sich statt Cortex A72.
Wir haben den Raspi 5 hier mal neben einem
Raspi 4 aufgebaut, ein paar Vergleichstest gemacht.
Der Raspi 5 ist auf jeden Fall deutlich schneller.
Also wir haben hier zum Beispiel der Jetstream 2.1 Browser Benchmark.
Wow, okay, okay, da spielt aber auch die Grafikkarte mit rein.
Da ist der Raspi 5 um den Faktor 2,4
mal so schnell wie der Raspi 4. Wir haben mit Sevenzip Kompression getestet.
Wow.
Aber ich meine, ich habe gesagt 30, 40 Prozent schneller.
Das ist einfach mal dreimal so schnell.
Okay, doppelt, doppelt, also doppelt bis dreifach so schnell.
Das ist viel mehr, als ich gedacht hätte.
Entpacken und packen.
Da war der Raspi 5 2,3 mal so schnell und bei OpenSSL, also Verschlüsselung sogar fast.
Gut, das ist oh, das ist nice.
Das heißt, die haben eine CPU, die haben eine CPU mit Krypto Extensions.
Das ist sehr gut.
Damit könnte sich zum ersten Mal ein Raspberry Pi 5 als NAS eignen.
Viele Leute waren in der Meinung, sie wollen sich ein NAS bauen.
Mit dem Raspberry Pi habe ich nie verstanden.
Jetzt könnte man ihn dafür wahrscheinlich sogar verwenden.
Schade, dass es keine 2,5 GHz Netzwerkschnittstelle hat.
Das heißt, es ist immer noch ein bisschen schwierig, wenn man ein ordentliches,
modernes, ein bisschen besseres Performance NAS haben möchte.
Kann der AV1-Encode,
er kann also decoden.
Zum ENCODEN habe ich noch nichts gesehen.
Hardware decoden, weil der das jetzt in Hardware kann.
Das ist schon ein großer Unterschied.
Und da spielt sicherlich auch mit rein, dass der Raspi 5 mehr CPU Cache und schnelleres.
Geht auch VPN Server Client besser?
Mit Sicherheit geht das besser, wenn die CPU Krypto Extensions hat.
Auch Full Disk Encryption wird deutlich besser funktionieren.
Ja, lass uns doch mal kurz gucken.
Ihr OpenSSL das Ding, das hat Krypto Extensions in der CPU.
Das ist tatsächlich der größte Pluspunkt
neben dem PCI Express, den ich bis jetzt gesehen habe.
Die Details stehen übrigens hier in der Tabelle.
Drückt gerne die Pause Taste.
Oben rein stecken auch Endschleuniger für Verschlüsselungsfunktionen wie AES im Raspi SoC.
Dadurch laufen Sachen wie OpenSSL und VPNs besser.
Der Graphic Chip Video Core 7 taktet 60 Prozent schneller als der
Vorgänger. Wie zuvor werden H265 kodierte Videos in Hardware dekodiert.
Die Codecs VP9 und AV1 müssen aber leider immer noch in Software dekodiert werden.
Das sind die Codecs, die z.B.
YouTube für Auflösungen ab 1080p und für HDR Videos verwendet.
4K Videos auf YouTube konnten wir zwar im Test trotzdem ruckelfrei abspielen, man
sieht aber doch super krasse CPU Last, wie der Prozessor dann aufdrehen muss.
Zum Vergleich.
So sieht die Auslastung bei einem H265 kodierten 4K Video aus.
Das ist deutlich weniger, weil es eben in Hardware dekodiert wird.
Wie zuvor gibt es wieder zwei Micro HDMI Buchsen, die jeweils ein 4K Display mit 60Hz anstellen.
Eine große Neuerung.
Exzellent. Der Name klingt ein bisschen nach...
...ist der neue.
Vielleicht aber auch nicht.
RP1 I.O. Chip.
Der kümmert sich unter anderem um USB, PCI Express, Ethernet und die 40 polige GPIO Leiste.
Beide USB 3.0 Ports können jetzt gleichzeitig mit 5 Gigabit pro Sekunde arbeiten.
Ganz neu ist der zusätzliche PCIe.
Gut.
Das bedeutet.
Wenn beide Ports jeweils 5 Gig, wenn die
sich das nicht mehr scheren, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, heißt das, man kann
theoretisch eine 2,5 oder 5 Gig USB Netzwerkkarte anbinden.
Was man ja braucht für einen ordentlichen...
Der USB Port ist schepp, ja.
Was man ja braucht, wenn man auch ein
bisschen ordentlich Datenübertragung auf seinen NAS haben möchte.
Wie gesagt, ich denke immer noch nicht, dass
der Raspberry Pi die beste Grundlage für NAS ist, aber viele wollen das ja machen.
Also man kann zum Beispiel schon mal...
Man könnte...
Zwar überlegen, wie schnell war PCI Express 2?
Ja, 500 MB die Sekunde.
Da haben wir da irgendwie eine ordentliche Tabelle.
Wie schnell das wie schnell das Ganze ist.
Wir haben eine PCI Express 2-fach, PCI Express 2 eine Lane.
So.
Das heißt, also ein halbes Gig.
Durch das Encoding, genau durch das
Encoding geht ja da wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen was verloren.
Heißt aber im Endeffekt eine 2,5 Gig Netzwerkkarte
könnte man relativ gut anschließen an das PCI Express Interface.
Und dann hätte man noch zwei USB 5 Gig Ports
frei für SSDs und Platten.
Damit könnte man prinzipiell denke ich
ein ganz gutes Netzwerk Storage bauen mit dem Raspberry Pi.
Hardware Encryption sorgt dafür, dass es auch...
CPU Last technisch nicht komplett durch die Decke geht bei vollverschlüsselter Platte.
Also ich denke mal...
Ich meine, man könnte man könnte natürlich auch ein USB, ein USB Port opfern dafür.
Da müsste man halt die...
Die Disks an irgendeinem USB Hub oder so hängen.
Mein 5 Gig reicht immer noch ganz gut aus für ein paar SATA bzw.
ein paar USB SSDs.
Wenn du hast, sagen wir mal,
so eine 0815 USB SSD, eine von den bisschen besseren.
Was machen die denn so?
400, 450 MB die Sekunde oder sowas.
Sind wir mal großzügig, sagen 500 MB,
dann kriegst du dann kriegst du trotzdem über so ein 5 Gig Port.
Kannst du, sagen wir mal, sind wir mal großzügig.
Sag mal, du schließt, du schließt vier daran an.
Es gibt ja immer noch ein bisschen Overhead durch alle mögliche Encoding.
Du kannst, könntest quasi vier Stück pro USB.
Ja, ich glaube, ich glaube, damit ist der
Raspberry Pi 5 zum ersten Mal wirklich brauchbar als Netzwerk Storage.
Gerade durch Hardware, durch Hardware Encryption.
Jetzt gleichzeitig mit 5 Gigabit pro Sekunde arbeiten.
Ganz neu ist der zusätzliche PCI Express
Anschluss PCIe 2.0 X1 mit bis zu 500 Megabyte pro Sekunde über den optionalen.
Also ich würde wahrscheinlich, ich würde es wahrscheinlich so machen.
Ich würde mir je nach Case.
Ich würde die Netzwerkkarte an das PCI Express anschließen und den Storage an USB.
Wenn es M2 hat, kann man SSDs dran anschließen, was natürlich praktisch ist.
Wenn man sich mit dem Raspi nass bauen beim Vierer Raspi musste man Platten oder
SSDs über USB anschließen, was aber auch immer okay funktioniert.
Ja gut, du hast ja gar keinen Platz für ich.
Weil man könnte sagen,
man macht das System auf die SSD, aber die
kann man auch auf die Micro SD Karte machen, weil bei einem Nass ist ja nicht so,
dass das System jetzt irgendwie super krassen Storage selbst braucht.
Ich habe seit zwei Jahren den Raspi 4
nass mit drei 5 Terabyte USB Festplatten völlig stabil laufen im Leerlauf.
Also wenn die Platten gerade nicht
hochgedreht sind, kommt das gesamte System auf eine Leistungsaufnahme von deutlich unter 10 Watt.
Da das System 24 7 läuft, ist es natürlich super, weil das so nur ein paar Euro
Stromkosten pro Jahr bedeutet, ohne
angeschlossene Platten, also nur der Raspi mit dem Betriebssystem auf Micro SD,
kommt der Raspi 4 im Leerlauf auf lediglich 3 Watt.
Und hier dann jetzt auch der erste Negativpunkt beim Raspi 5.
Die höhere Rechenpower braucht natürlich auch mehr Strom.
Das Minimum, was wir beim Fünfer gemessen haben, waren 3,3 Watt.
Beim Raspi 4 sind es 2,7 Watt.
Ja, das geht aber immer noch klar.
Bei Vollauslastung zieht der Raspi 5 ohne.
Ich rate mal, ich rate jetzt mal kurz.
Okay, also ich denke mal 20 Watt.
Dürfte der Raspberry Pi 5 schon ziehen in Vollauslastung?
Weil ich glaube, beim beim Vierer waren es irgendwie 13 oder sowas.
Ich sage mal um die 20.
18, 20, 19, 20 Watt, der Raspi 4 nur 6,4 Watt.
7,7, das geht ja noch höher.
Sind im Leerlauf 22 Prozent mehr und bei Last 34 Prozent.
Also ich finde die Werte ganz schön okay dafür, dass man sich anguckt, wie viel mehr
Leistung der Raspi 5 bringt.
Sind diese maximal 34 Prozent mehr Leistungsaufnahme völlig okay, würde ich sagen.
Was ich nur noch zeigen muss, ist, wie das Ganze mit der Temperatur sich verhält.
Wenn man immer einen Lüfter braucht, das wäre natürlich ein ziemliches No-Go.
Das war beim Raspberry Pi 4 schon so, dass der ziemlich warm geworden ist.
Das Schöne ist, dass die meisten Leute auf den Raspberry Pis eben keinen Workload haben,
der dort dauerhaft hohe CPU-Last verursacht.
Die haben mal ein bisschen.
Die brauchen mal ein bisschen Rechenpower für zwei, drei Minuten vielleicht, wenn es
hochkommt, aber danach ist das Ding wieder aus.
Deswegen bin ich ein großer Fan von diesem von diesem Case.
Das ist komplett passiv gekühlt.
Und das Case ist halt ein großer Passivkühler.
Das funktioniert allerdings wiederum nicht richtig gut.
Natürlich, wenn man konstant immer Volllast hat, weil irgendwann ist das Case heiß.
Und wenn du dann keinerlei Luftzug drumherum hast und die Luft da steht.
Naja, irgendwann wird es trotzdem heiß, ganz ohne Lüfter.
Aber für mal ein paar Minuten richtig volle Pulle, hoher Load ist das richtig gut.
Raspberry Pis sind glücklicherweise so gebaut, die takten sich dann eher runter
und die kacken nicht einfach ab, wenn die zu heiß werden.
Ja, das ist nicht so wild.
Man hat halt ein bisschen Performance Einbußen.
Also wenn man jetzt wirklich 24 7 das Ding auf Anschlag laufen lassen will, dann ist
das Case vielleicht nix, aber so gut wie niemand hat das.
Weil egal, was du damit machst, es sind meistens ein paar Bursts,
wo du mal ordentliche CPU Last hast oder vielleicht auch konstant, aber konstant
dann eher 20, 30 Prozent und nicht konstant 100.
Also dieses Case finde ich mega nice.
Habe ich auch auf allen meinen Raspberry Pis.
Stimmt nicht.
Plötzlich nicht auf allen, aber auf vielen.
Raspberry Pis, bestimmt auf vier Stück.
Es gibt es auch noch für die Raspberry 3 Version.
Also auf allen Raspberry Pi 4 habe ich das Case und ich habe auch noch eine
Raspberry 3 Version gibt es hier irgendwo noch Option.
Gibt es auch für Raspberry Pi 3, das FLIR Case.
Gibt es sogar für Raspberry Pi Zeroes.
Also mega, mega nice ist das Case.
Auch zwingend ein Power Delivery fähiges USB-C Netzteil anschließend, das 5 Ampere liefert.
Der 4er Raspi brauchte noch kein Power Delivery Netzteil.
Normales mit 3 Ampere reichen hier.
Und er braucht im Normalfall auch keinen aktiven Lüfter.
Beim Raspi 5 ist das ein bisschen anders.
Man kann den zwar ohne Lüfter nutzen.
Die Raspberry Pi Foundation rät aber vom
lüfterlosen Betrieb in engen Gehäusen ab.
Ja, und da ist auch erstmals ein Lüfteranschluss auf der Platine.
Finde ich gut, dass ein Lüfteranschluss auf der Platine ist.
Ich würde mal drauf tippen.
Mit dem normalen Workload, den die Leute da drauf laufen haben,
ist so ein FLIR Case immer noch eine gute Wahl.
Leider passen dann dank dem neuen Chipsatz, der neuen Grafikkarte und so,
wird das alte FLIR Case wahrscheinlich nicht mehr drauf passen.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Außerdem nicht so schön.
Der Raspi 5 ist zwar genauso groß wie der Raspi 4, aber Ethernet und USB-Buchse sind
vertauscht beim neuen. Man kann also die alten Gehäuse nicht mehr verwenden, braucht man neue.
Und so ein Power Delivery Netzteil ist halt auch eine ganze Ecke.
Teurer als ein normales USB-C Netzteil mit drei Ampere.
Fazit Bevor ich meine eigene Meinung sage, habe ich
noch Christoph Windeck nach seiner Einschätzung zum Raspi 5 gefragt.
Das ist, wenn der Christoph das sagt, dann muss das so sein.
Die absolute CT-Hardware-Koryphäe.
Ich kann hier an dieser Stelle Christophs Podcast Bitrauschen echt empfehlen.
Der Link ist in der Beschreibung.
Der Raspberry Pi 5 bringt jetzt 2023, also vier Jahre nach dem Raspberry Pi 4,
ein wirklich großes Update bei der Rechenleistung.
Die Bauform bleibt ja gleich.
Das kommt einem gar nicht so lange vor.
Das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, weil der zwei Jahre nicht lieferbar war.
Im Grunde hat man darauf gewartet, auf diesen Chip, der wieder vier Kerne hat,
aber eben deutlich stärkere Rechenkerne, die höher getaktet sind, mehr Cache haben.
Endlich auch eine Beschleunigung für Krypto-Algorithmen.
Das ist irgendwie um den Fall.
Das ist für mich eines der größten Pluspunkte für den neuen Raspberry Pi,
dass die Krypto-Extensions dabei in der CPU haben.
Faktor 18 schneller als der Vorgänger.
Also damit dringt der Raspberry Pi 5 in die Zeit.
Da kommen neue Leistungsbereiche vor.
Er ist ja auch ein bisschen teurer.
Das heißt, der Raspberry Pi 4 oder sogar der 3, die bleiben interessant für Projekte,
die nicht so viel Rechenleistung brauchen.
Der Raspberry Pi 5 ist dann wirklich sozusagen das Rechentier.
Relativ gesehen zu anderen ARM-Chips.
Also er kann natürlich nicht mit einem Desktop-PC mit 18 Kernen oder so mithalten.
Aber er bringt ganz neue Möglichkeiten, wenn es um Rechenleistung geht.
Also besonders gespannt bin ich auf den Adapter für
PCI Express, sodass man an den Raspberry endlich eine NVMe-SSD anschließen kann.
Warum? Ich verstehe es gar nicht, warum da alle so scharf drauf sind.
Das ist PCI Express 2.0 einfach.
Da hast du mit SATA-SSDs geschafft, die Geschwindigkeit.
Da ist der NVMe-SSD voll verschenkt.
Dann schließe ich lieber eine SSD an.
Per USB.
Die ist genauso schnell, externe USB und potenziell sogar schneller.
Ich verstehe nicht so ganz, warum die da so scharf drauf sind.
Nicht nur, damit er schneller startet, sondern weil das auch neue Möglichkeiten eröffnet
als kleiner Mini-Home-Server.
Das ist zwar jetzt nicht super schnell
angebunden, aber besser als alles, was wir bisher kannten.
Und ja, leider ist der Adapter noch nicht
dabei gewesen in unserem Testpaket und ich bin sehr gespannt, was der bringt.
Ja, und ich? Ich bin echt ziemlich heiß drauf, mehr mit dem Raspberry 5 rumzuspielen.
Ich habe mir schon fest vorgenommen, eine Woche lang das Teil als Haupt-Arbeitsrechner zu verwenden.
Und werde dazu natürlich auch ein Video machen, das ich da so erlebt habe.
Als Heim-Server tut es mein alter Raspberry 4 allerdings noch locker.
Den werde ich erst mal nicht umstellen.
Vor allem wegen der geringen Leistungsaufnahme.
Richtig gespannt bin ich aber auf die
Performance vom Raspberry 5 als Retro-Spiel-Konsole.
Mit den Linux-Distries Retro-Pi oder Bato-Serra konnte man den Vierer ja schon
bis ungefähr dem Nintendo 64 ganz gut nutzen.
Die Frage ist, wird mit dem Raspberry 5 auch die nächste Konsolengeneration ruckelfrei zu emulieren sein?
Also PS2, Gamecube und so was?
Ich finde es ziemlich aufregend.
Was meint ihr? Seid ihr heiß auf den Raspberry 5 oder sind Raspis für euch out?
Gerne in die Kommentare schreiben. Tschüss.
See you.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Willi wills wissen, Clips ohne Code?
Nein, da kommen wir jetzt nicht rein.
Kannste, kannste machen.
Es gibt doch, es gibt doch sogar schon Tower-Kühler für...
Der Task-Manager-Sourcecode wurde revealed.
Ehrlich gesagt finde ich den Task-Manager nicht sonderlich spannend.
Es gibt doch sogar schon Raspberry Pi.
Gibt es doch sogar schon so einen Tower-Kühler.
Habe ich doch letztens irgendwo gesehen.
Ja, sowas hier.
Ich finde es halt total unhandlich und fragwürdig.
Ja,
weil eines der größten Vorteile davon ist halt der kleine Formfaktor.
Und wenn du da so einen Tower-Kühler drauf stellst, fragt man sich so halt, ok,
was ist denn da?
Also, ich meine, es hat auch noch RGB.
Außer, dass man vielleicht sagen kann, das sieht cool aus.
So wirklich, also außer dem sieht cool aus Faktor kann ich jetzt nichts.
So kann ich persönlich jetzt der Sache wenig abgewinnen.
Overclocken. Ja, wenn das notwendig ist.
Wenn ihr die paar Prozent Leistung von Anwendung geht, geht nicht.
Da würde mich natürlich mal interessieren, was das ist.
Aber ist eher just for fun.
Raspberry Pi Case mit Sichtwert.
Das wird's. Das gibt's.
Das gibt's wahrscheinlich schon jetzt bestimmt schon.
Mit Glas zum reingucken.
Okay, es gibt.
Es gibt diese Durchsicht, die gibt's, die gibt's, die gibt's schon eine Weile.
Das kommt bestimmt als nächstes.
Als nächstes baut einer so eine.
Als nächstes gibt's dann bestimmt ein.
Wie heißt der Hersteller?
Fractal Fractal Design Raspberry Pi Case.
Haben die vielleicht schon so was?
Nee, haben sie nicht.
Gibt's nicht.
Das wäre es jetzt.
Und dann, dann mit mit Glas Scheibe.
Was cooler Master.
Echt?
Da ist im Raspberry Pi aber nichts zu tun.
Das sind RAM.
Wie man auf RAM mit RGB kommt.
Warum RAM mit RGB ist doch POG.
Cooler Master Raspberry Pi.
Sieht auf jeden Fall recht stylisch aus.
Wobei ich sagen muss, sieht fast schon ein bisschen schlecht.
3D druckt aus.
Ganz ehrlich, FLIR CASE.
Ein IDE Kabel, dass ich das noch mal sehen darf in 2023.
Ach so, das ist für so eine Hut, Hut Schiene.
Die Idee finde ich aber gar nicht schlecht, dass man das in den Schaltschrank hängen kann.
Und ich finde, da macht der Lüfter sogar noch irgendwie Sinn, weil das ja sehr
enges,
beengtes.
Ja, Umgebung ist in so einem Schaltschrank.
Wollen Max hast schon gesehen, dass Lidl jetzt auch Cloud anbieten will.
Also, dass sie das jetzt anbieten wollen.
Öffentlich wusste ich nicht, aber das Lidl irgendwelche eigenen Clouder.
Waren die nicht sogar auf OpenStack Basis bei Lidl?
Das habe ich schon öfters gehört.
Wie kommst du da in der Lidl Cloud?
Also, dass Lidl da in dem Sektor tätig ist, das wusste ich.
Okay, Lidl Cloud will Amazon AWS Konkurrenz machen.
Das bezweifle ich, dass das funktionieren wird.
Dann schon. Ich meine,
die Telekom hat ja auch so was.
Nennt sich Magenta Cloud.
Ich habe, ich habe mal bei einem, bei einer Azure Schulung gefragt, weil die haben
irgendwas von Backup und Migration erzählt.
Und da habe ich den gefragt, ob man auch zur Magenta Cloud migrieren könnte.
Da hat er nur blöd geguckt.
Und er hat dazu abgewunken, so.
Okay, Lidl Cloud will Amazons AWS Konkurrenz machen.
IT Schwarz, ja, Schwarz Digits wird.
Cloud Dienste und IT Security anbieten.
Das machen die jetzt auch schon.
Genau Lidl.
Der Handelskonzern Lidl und Kaufland will Amazon und anderen US Konzernen im Cloud
Geschäft Konkurrenz machen.
Bla, bla, bla.
Wir wollen alle unterstützen, die diese komplexen Themen nicht alleine angehen
können, die sich aber nicht abhängig machen wollen von großen Konzernen außerhalb
Europas. Gut, da machst du dich halt von einem Konzern innerhalb Europas abhängig.
Gut, bei manchen wird das policymäßig besser sein.
Das Ding ist halt einfach die,
jeder Cloud Anbieter macht, hat andere Sachen, zwar viele Überschneidungen, aber
auch andere Sachen und die machen auch Sachen ein bisschen unterschiedlich.
Und bei Google und Amazon
und Microsoft hast du immerhin den Vorteil.
Es gibt sehr viele Tutorials und Sachen, die du nachgucken kannst.
Bei Schwarz IT würde ich mal, hört sich fast schon illegal an, oder?
Bei Schwarz IT bin ich mir nicht so sicher, was da an
öffentlich zugänglichen Tutorials und und Support und Unterstützung gibt.
Gibt es überhaupt Cloud Provider, die DSGVO konform sind?
Ja, also beispielsweise Google.
Ja, aber das ist ja nicht so einfach, weil
Google sagt, sie speichern die Sachen nur in Rechenzentren in Europa.
Letztendlich musst du dich immer auf die Aussage der Hersteller verlassen.
Weil nur weil ein Unternehmen in Europa
sitzt, sagt es ja nichts über den Datenspeicherungsstand aus.
Du machst dann Verträge mit denen, wo das drin steht, und da steht auch drin, das muss
so und so sein und die verpflichten sich dazu, dass es so ist.
Ob das wirklich letztendlich dann so ist?
Wer weiß?
Dann kannst du aber prinzipiell keinen der großen Cloud Anbieter verwenden.
Also wir haben sehr krasse Auflagen von mir auf der Arbeit und es ist okay, wenn
man die Sachen beispielsweise bei Google speichert, sofern das halt.
Unter diesen Bedingungen erfolgt.
Google bietet auch, bietet glaube ich auch
werbetechnisch sogar das Recht offensiv an, dass sie DSGVO konform sein können.
Okay, was machen sie denn sonst noch so?
Oh, rund anderthalb Jahren bla bla bla.
Genau das ist ein großes Geschäft.
Wir sind überzeugt, dass in den nächsten
Jahren die Marktposition für IT-Lösungen erfolgreich ausbauen kann.
Ja, gut, das sagt ja nichts.
Vor allem schon jetzt haben das eine deutliche dreistellige Zahl von Partnern
auf seinen auf seiner Cloud, mit denen die Produkte entwickelt.
Was?
Dreistellige Anzahl von Partnern.
Das kann ja nun wirklich alles bedeuten.
Außerdem sind dreistellige Anzahlen für den Cloud Anbieter, dreistellige Anzahl an
Kunden jetzt nun wirklich nicht viel.
Dreistellig sind 100 Kunden, Leute.
Wenn ich 100 Kunden habe als Cloud Anbieter
oder 150, wer weiß, was der deutlich dreistelliger Zahl meint oder 400.
Das ist jetzt ja nicht wirklich viel.
Was?
Stack, Stack ist schon eine Cloud Plattform, die wohl so schlecht sein,
dass die Mitarbeiter lieber GCP oder Azure nutzen.
Das wundert mich nicht, aber kann ich so nichts sagen.
Ich kenne das nicht. Zeig mal hier, Stackit.
Die deutsche Cloud
machen sie jetzt unsere leistungsstarken Cloud Lösung 100 Prozent made in Germany.
100 Prozent garantiert Preise.
Lass uns doch mal checken hier.
IAS.
Ja.
Stackit, Stackit Compute Engine.
Okay, das gucken wir mal.
Machen wir, machen wir das Ganze mal ein bisschen monatlich.
Okay, preislich, preislich geht das, finde ich recht gut klar.
Ich meine wirklich viel sind da sind da Public IPs und so schon mit drin.
Ich meine, wirklich große Sprünge kann man damit nicht machen.
Aber wenn man was Kleines braucht, was öffentlich verfügbar ist im Internet,
dann mag das durchaus durchaus Sinn machen.
Kommen wir mal zu ein bisschen.
Ja, das ist aber schon ganz schön teuer.
Ich meine, das sind ja fast Google Preise.
Google Cloud Rechner und Google ist schon teuer as fuck.
Vergleichen wir das mal kurz.
Also bei hier Hetzner Cloud Pricing.
Bezahlst du für die, bezahlst du für eine vier, vier Kerne.
Preises, das ist auch, das ist Dedicated.
Ja, bezahlst du 29 Euro, bezahlst du einfach mal ein Drittel davon.
Das ist auch hundertprozentig made in Germany.
Ja, du kannst die Location sogar selbst auswählen.
Hetzner gab es bis vor kurzem sogar nur in Finnland und Deutschland.
Mittlerweile seit einem Jahr oder so haben die auch was in den USA.
Hetzner ist keine Cloud.
Das ist korrekt, aber wir vergleichen ja in dem Fall auch nur VMS und das können
die auch alle anderen Sachen, weil man sieht ja hier mehr sieht man ja hier gar nicht.
Und man sieht.
Okay, gucken wir mal Runtime.
Was haben sonst noch?
Kubernetes, SKE, was kostet das?
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Preisübersicht.
Okay, zehn Service Instanzen.
Was wollen die mir damit?
Was wollen die mir damit sagen?
Okay, das heißt, du bezahlst nicht pro
Cluster Note, sondern für insgesamt oder wie?
Ja, das Problem ist, dass du in Kubernetes gar nicht genau sagen kannst.
Also meinen die wirklich ein Kubernetes Service?
Also dann kommst du mit fünf Service
Definitionen definitiv nicht weit und mit zehn auch nicht.
Machst du einen Helminstall Prometheus fürs Monitoring?
Da hast du schon 15 Services oder so.
Also weiß man gar nicht genau, was die meinen.
Kostet was?
Jawoll, Loadbalancer.
Kennt die jemand?
Was sind die?
Jawoll, Loadbalancer.
Okay, gibt es sogar
ganze 37 Sterne.
Reise.
Okay, wenn du eine kleine Google Kubernetes, wenn du einen kleinen GKE Cluster
brauchst, da kostet ungefähr im Monat das gleiche.
Aber das ist
das ist zusätzlich noch mal oder?
Pro Cluster pro Stunde.
Wait a minute.
Hä?
Pro Cluster Stunde pro Monat?
Ja, Moment.
Wie jetzt?
Pro Cluster pro Stunde pro Monat?
Jetzt quick maths.
Jetzt macht man hier nicht mehr nicht mehr nicht mehr mit.
Die Abrechnung ist pro Stunde.
Ah, okay.
Im Monat im Monat kostet das dann so viel zusammen.
Bisschen unübersichtlich.
Also ich meine selbst Google, wenn man hier mal die Google Compute Engine nehmen.
Instance ist eins.
Das ist wurscht.
Das ist ein regular E2 Standard.
Das sind die.
What the fuck?
Ah, material Design auf dem Desktop.
So, 460, guck mal, gibt's gar nicht.
Gibt's gar nicht.
So, dann nehmen wir mal hier 2, 2.
Man kann, glaube ich, auch Custom.
Custom Machine Type hier kommen.
4 und 8 Gig.
Ein Balanced Disk, wir lassen mal alles, wir lassen mal alles.
Default. Kostet sich 80 Dollar.
Ich mein.
Fucking Google.
Okay, in Iowa sind wir.
Wobei das wahrscheinlich nicht so viel Unterschied macht.
Best 3.
Oh Gott, das Ding ist so abartig, man.
Wie speichere ich das jetzt?
So, ne, ist immer noch in Iowa.
Okay, Leute, ich hab legit keine Ahnung, wie ich das erde.
Aber das macht doch keinen Unterschied.
Das kostet überall mehr oder weniger.
Das ist das Gleiche.
Ja, guck mal, kostbar Google 80.
Gut, natürlich muss man noch ein bisschen schauen, wie es mit Traffic ist.
Und die E-Dinger sind auch, sind auch ein bisschen
low endiger und billiger.
Ja, also keine Ahnung.
Ich wüsste zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht, warum ich was anderes nehmen sollte, außer
Azure, Google oder AWS. Und ich persönlich würde mich zwischen
Azure und Google entscheiden, weil ich von AWS mit Abstand den wenigsten Plan hab.
So, IT-Leiter aus dem Mittelstand sind die Zielgruppe.
Ja, gerade für die wär's ja nice aus dem Mittelstand.
Wär's ja nice, wenn es eine bekannte große
Plattform ist, weil man eben Leute findet für bekannte große Plattformen, weil man
Schulungen, Know-how und Tutorials für große Plattformen findet.
Für, für, für
Schwarz, Gruppe, Cloud weniger, hä?
Vielleicht meinen die auch, sie können
mittelständische Leiter besser beschwätzen, ihr Marketing-Team.
Neben Markenlehne ist das schon...
Ja gut, mein Wollen können sie ja mal.
Beispielsweise unsere Stackit Cloud oder das Cyber-Sicherheitsangebot von XM Cyber.
Der Name ist schon so unglaublich dumm,
dass ich mir niemals freiwillig was von XM Cyber holen würde.
XM Cyber, Mann.
Der Name ist schon... XM Cyber.
Naja, was sagt denn, was sagt denn das Forum dazu?
Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass ich das nennenswert durchsetzen wird.
Hoffentlich nicht.
So, was können wir uns denn hier noch geben?
Chat, ihr meint, das ist ein gutes Video.
Soll ich machen? Ich weiß nicht, ob ich mir 37 Minuten Video angucken kann.
Ihr wisst, dass ich ein 37 Minuten Video unter einer Stunde nicht durchkriege.
Yep, okay.
Nee, das ist, glaube ich, zu hart.
Das ist, das ist mir, das ist mir für jetzt zu
harte Kost.
Privilege Escalation gefunden.
Eine Privilege Escalation.
Das ist mir zu harte Kost für heute Morgen.
Das ist bestimmt super gemacht und bestimmt auch spannend.
Aber das ist eher was für einen Stream abends.
Das ist für Noobs erklärt.
Ja, das ist ja schon gut, aber das wird...
Okay, okay, Chatge, wenn ihr wollt, wollen wir das gucken jetzt?
Also wir hätten wir, ansonsten hätten wir noch ein paar andere Sachen.
Keine Ahnung, zur Auswahl.
Okay.
Wenn ihr auf YouTube Deutschland unterwegs seid, dann wisst ihr, dass Leeroy in letzter Zeit öfters
in der Kritik steht.
Was ist da? Es ist vorbei bei Google.
So, so, weil es irgendein Random...
Weil irgendein Random-Dude sagt, es ist vorbei.
Okay.
Leute, ich muss mal ein paar Tabs zumachen.
So viel.
Okay, dann let's go.
Und mit seinem letzten Video hat er wieder ins Klo gegriffen.
Aber nicht, weil er VPNs mit falschen Versprechungen beworben hat.
Das heißt, du schützt dich vor Viren und Cyberangriffen.
VPNs schützen natürlich...
Naja, gut.
Dumme VPN-Werbung macht ja mittlerweile fast jeder.
Sogar ich hätte mal fast dumme VPN-Werbung gemacht.
Aber die haben dann von mir verlangt, dass ich mein Video über VPNs löschen soll.
Habe ich gesagt, da mache ich keine Werbung für VPN-Anbieter.
Ich habe ja mal ein Video gemacht.
Lügen VPN-Anbieter.
Das da, was sogar relativ erfolgreich gewesen ist und das gefällt denen nicht.
Dass ich das Video habe und das wollten die, dass ich das...
Die wollten, dass ich das Video lösche, dass sie bei mir dann Werbung machen.
Da habe ich gesagt, ja, dann macht ihr halt bei mir keine Werbung.
Natürlich nicht vor Cyberangriffen oder Viren.
Da gab es auch diesen netten Kommentar unter seinem Video, sondern wegen seinem Interviewgast.
Ich muss aber auch sagen und Leroy hier ein bisschen in Schutz nehmen.
Er hätte das nicht besser wissen können.
Über Jean Pereira existieren viele Newsartikel und er ist auch sehr aktiv auf LinkedIn mit sehr viel positiven Kommentaren.
Weil er natürlich die Negativen löscht, aber dazu gleich mehr.
Das heißt, von außen sieht alles tippitopp aus, aber deswegen bin ich hier und ich versuche das für euch...
Kennt ihr den Kerl?
Also nicht ihn, sondern den, um den es hier geht.
Von dem habe ich noch nie was gehört.
Ja.
Er ist auch sehr aktiv auf...
Jean Pereira oder wie auch immer.
Habe ich noch nie gehört.
LinkedIn mit sehr viel positiven Kommentaren, weil er natürlich die Negativen löscht, aber dazu gleich mehr.
Das heißt, von außen sieht alles tippitopp aus, aber deswegen bin ich hier und ich versuche das für euch mal ein bisschen einzuordnen.
Wir gehen gleich in den Deep Dive, in die Hacker-Szene, in die richtige Hacker-Szene.
Hacker-Szene, nicht dieses Bullshit, Anonymous und was weiß ich.
Ich meine, ich habe auch meine Arbeitskleidung, meine Kutte, aber die holt man nur raus zu irgendwelchen Anlässen.
In dem Video werden einige großartige Claims gemacht, aber die Welt ist nicht so schlimm, wie die da dargestellt wird.
Und ich hoffe, am Ende könnt ihr das auch ein bisschen besser einordnen.
Bevor wir jetzt in das Video rein starten, fragt ihr euch vielleicht, wieso sollt ihr mir glauben oder mir zuhören?
Ganz einfach, weil ich weiß, dass er Ahnung hat.
Also erst mal mache ich mir jetzt erst mal eine Mate auf.
Und das ist der erste Beweis.
Schau mal, richtige Hacker-Man.
Ihr denkt vielleicht, das ist nur ein Berliner Hipster-Getränk, aber tatsächlich hat es so ein bisschen seinen Ursprung.
Wieso es populär wurde in der deutschen Hacker-Szene, kann alles nachgelesen werden auf Wikipedia.
Das heißt, das war euer erster Fun Fact übers Hacking.
Aber die viel wichtigeren Credentials sind eigentlich mein Hauptkanal.
Ihr seid gerade auf meinem Zweitkanal und das ist mein erstes deutsches Video, das ich ever mache, glaube ich.
Weil auf dem Erstkanal Live Overflow mache ich Videos in Englisch.
Damit erreiche ich einfach mehr Leute.
Und Live Overflow gehört zu den größten IT-Security-YouTube-Kanälen, die existieren.
Und ihr fragt euch sicherlich, wie kann das denn sein, dass Hacking auf YouTube, wird das nicht gebannt und keine Ahnung was und so.
Ja, wenn ihr dumme, langweilige Credit-Card-Fraud oder Phishing oder sowas macht, so lame Sachen so, dann ja, dann werdet ihr vielleicht gesperrt.
Aber wenn man so das Hacking richtig professionell angeht und so weiter, dann muss man da nichts befürchten.
Ich hatte nie Probleme mit meinen Videos und andere Kanäle, die Probleme mit Videos hatten, das wurde auch immer resolved.
Und Fun Fact, ich habe mehrere Videos, die von Google gesponsert wurden.
Google hat Videos gesponsert, wo ich dann über Sicherheitslücken in Google berichtet habe.
Von außen sieht diese Hacker-Welt immer so crazy böse und keine Ahnung was aus, aber am Ende ist das auch einfach nur Leute, die halt abhängen und coole Sachen machen wollen.
Deshalb, wenn ihr so ein bisschen meine Credentials verstehen wollt, schaut einfach ein bisschen auf meinem Hauptkanal rum.
Ich habe sogar eine Minecraft-Hacking-Serie.
Meine populärste Serie ist wahrscheinlich die Binary-Exploitation-Serie.
Auf meiner Webseite liveoverflow.com starthacking habe ich auch so ein paar Gedanken, so wenn ihr damit anfangen wollt und so, was ihr machen könnt.
Und wichtig zu erwähnen ist, dass ich YouTube nur nebenher mache.
Ich habe ganz wenig Kooperationen, weil ich überhaupt keinen Bock habe auf das Zeug.
Mein Geld verdiene ich eigentlich mit Security-Audits und so.
Also mein täglich Brot ist, ich suche nach Sicherheitslücken und reporte die zu Firmen und so.
Und da gibt es auch einige Public-Reports, die man auch finden kann, wenn man möchte.
Anyway, ich hoffe, ihr könnt jetzt mich so ein bisschen mehr einschätzen.
Deshalb lasst uns jetzt mal in Leroy's Interview gehen.
Und lasst uns einfach mal mit einem Kommentar starten.
Kann man das nachweisen, dass das alles stimmt?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
In dem Video werden konstant irgendwelche Claims gemacht und es ist fast ein bisschen unmöglich, auf alles einzugehen.
Aber es gibt so zwei Sachen im Speziellen, wo ich ein bisschen tiefer reingehen möchte.
Und das erste bezieht sich auf eine Software.
Die nennt sich Hospital Run.
Führen wir mal kurz in das Interview rein, was er da sagt.
Ich habe was in einer Software veröffentlicht, die nennt sich Hospital Run.
Und da gibt es die Möglichkeit, die Blutgruppen auszutauschen in der Software.
Und ich kann auch alle Blutgruppen auf einmal austauschen.
Also er sagt, er hat eine Sicherheitslücke gefunden in der Software, die Hospital Run heißt.
Tatsächlich wurde mir, als er das gefunden hatte und veröffentlicht hat auf LinkedIn, wurde mir das damals geschickt.
Und ich habe das erstmal so angeguckt und dachte so, hm, ja, sieht ein bisschen...
Das ist so ein Ding?
Also.
Ich kenne jetzt diesen konkreten Fall nicht.
Das ist viel zu abstrakt, was der gerade gesagt hat, um irgendwas nachvollziehen zu können.
Ja, ich habe da eine Software.
Ja, da ist dann Hospital im Namen drin.
Und das heißt, das muss auch was mit Krankenhäusern zu tun haben.
Und ja, ey Leute, ich kann auch eine Software veröffentlichen, die Hospital Run heißt.
Und dann auf meinem Terminal auf einmal eine andere Blutgruppe steht.
Ist halt die Frage, ob das wirklich was mit Krankenhäusern zu tun hat.
Aber gucken wir mal.
Guck mal, was er sagt.
Mit der sich ein Angreifer voll Zugriff auf medizinische Geräte verschaffen kann, sprich vollständiger Ruhzugriff.
Welche medizinischen Geräte, über welche Wege überhaupt?
Musst du dich dran stöpseln?
Musst du das aufschrauben?
WiFi, Bluetooth, irgendwelche Spezialprodukte?
Man weiß es nicht, ja.
Weil ich meine einfach nur die Software bei sich irgendwie aufs Notebook hauen und ausführen.
Das alleine wird ja wahrscheinlich nichts machen.
Ich habe das ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen ignoriert, weil ich auch irgendwie keinen Bock hatte, mir das jetzt genau anzugucken.
In dem LinkedIn-Text hat er so ein bisschen übertrieben, so wie krass das alles ist mit Krankenhäuser-Hacken und so weiter.
Aber ganz ehrlich, Leute machen ständig irgendwie so komische Claims und ich belächle das einfach immer so ein bisschen.
Aber dann haben befreundete Hacker mir gesagt, schau dir das mal ein bisschen genauer an.
Und das habe ich dann gemacht.
Und dann habe ich realisiert, dieser Exploit ist Bullshit.
Das war auch das erste Mal, dass ich von Jean Pereira was gehört habe.
Okay, okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Also, Buffer, irgendwelches Binary-Zeug, Payload.
Binary-Zeug, was auch immer.
File Open, Applications, Hospital Run App, Elektron, was so.
Auf Mac, seit wann laufen irgendwelche medizinischen Geräte auf Mac-Basis?
Ich dachte, die laufen noch auf Windows 98.
Oder Windows XP.
Windows XP habe ich ja live gesehen, als ich in der Notaufnahme im Krankenhaus war.
Windows XP-Bildschirm schon da erstmal angegangen.
Ja, das ist ja gut.
Das ergibt, also, wahrscheinlich kann er da noch deutlich mehr rein interpretieren, aber
allein schon, dass du das lokal auf einem Gerät ausführen musst,
was anscheinend auf Mac-OS-Basis läuft, und du musst es erstmal auf das Gerät draufbekommen.
Du musst es dann erstmal ausgeführt bekommen.
Und was bitte schön mit Elektron...
Oh, ich habe den Chat-Card reloaded.
Das ist so ein Tar im Endeffekt.
Also, okay, mal gucken, was er sagt.
Ich bin so aufgeregt, dass ich auf dem Hauptkanal darüber ein Video gemacht habe.
Wenn ihr da technisch ein bisschen tiefer einsteigen wollt und meine Einschätzung zu diesem Exploit sehen wollt,
ein bisschen in einem längeren Format, dann checkt auf jeden Fall das Video aus.
Aber ich versuche es mal ganz kurz zu...
Ey, das ist eigentlich eine richtig geile Serie für ihn, oder?
Sowas wie Hacker debunked Hacker.
Da kannst du richtig rein auf YouTube.
Hacking debunked.
Hacking Mythbusters.
Zusammenzufassen hier.
Erstens seht ihr, dass da steht Beta.
Es geht also um eine Beta-Version.
Von einer Software.
Diese Software war nie in Krankenhäusern irgendwie eingesetzt.
Und vor allem, warum auf Mac-Basis?
Das war irgendwie ein einzelner Entwickler oder sowas, der auf GitHub da irgendwie so eine Software da entwickelt hat.
Und wie gesagt, das war eine Testversion, eine Beta-Version.
Die hat überhaupt keine Relevanz in der Wirklichkeit.
Und dazu kommt noch, dass er claimt, er hat hier eine Privilege-Escalation gefunden.
Eine Privilege-Escalation-Sicherheitslücke bedeutet, dass du zum Beispiel von einem normalen Nutzer Administrationsrechte bekommen kannst.
Ja, das hat ja mit der Software wenigstens wenig zu tun.
Der bräuchte tatsächlich eine Sicherheitslücke.
Eine Sicherheitslücke in macOS für, ja, so Root-Exploit-mäßig.
Und da hätte er wahrscheinlich bei Apple ganz gut Kohle für so abgreifen können.
Die haben doch sicherlich irgendein Programm.
Nehmen wir den Exploit, also dass die Sicherheitslücke dann ausnutzt.
Und das ist einfach unmöglich mit dieser Software, wenn diese Software einfach nur als der normale Nutzer läuft.
Da gibt es einfach technisch gesehen, das ist einfach, das geht nicht.
Du kannst einfach nicht von User zu Admin, wenn da nichts als Admin läuft.
Und der Grund ist, wieso ich das richtig einschätzen kann, ist, weil ich habe solche Privilege-Escalation-Issues oft gefunden.
Ich habe das auch in einem anderen Video gezeigt.
Vieles meiner Arbeit ist natürlich für Kunden und so weiter, ist nicht öffentlich.
Aber wir haben ein paar VPN-Kunden, wo diese Security-Reports öffentlich sind.
Zum Beispiel TunnelBear.
Und in dem TunnelBear-Report, wo mein Name draufsteht, das könnt ihr da sehen, da habe ich Privilege-Escalation-Exploits reportet.
Aber das macht da auch Sinn, weil dieser VPN, der hat einen Privileged-Helper, der als Administrator läuft und eine normale User-Komponente.
Und wenn du dann irgendwie das abusen kannst, dann kannst du halt irgendwie einen Privileged-Helper übernehmen und bist dann Administrator.
Das macht Sinn.
Das macht Sinn, weil es da zwei Komponenten gibt.
Aber in Hospital Run gibt es das nicht.
In Hospital Run, das läuft einfach als User, das ist einfach unmöglich.
Deshalb, es macht einfach gar keinen Sinn.
Und dann auch technisch, dieser Code, der hier sieht, der benutzt Wörter, die wirklich eine Bedeutung haben.
Also Buffer, Payload.
Wisst ihr, was ich sehr merkwürdig finde?
Oder macht man das in Python so in einem String, irgendein Bytes Escape als String?
Normalerweise hätte ich halt irgendein ganz normales Array genommen und Bytes.
Byte-Values reingeschrieben, aber doch nicht als String zusammen.
Ja, macht man so? Okay.
Knobsled, das sind wirklich technische Begriffe aus der Hacking-Szene.
Und für jemand, der da nur so ein bisschen casual draufguckt und der sich nicht so richtig auskennt, das sieht auf den ersten Blick erstmal legit aus.
Aber wenn man das dann so ein bisschen decoded und so ein bisschen aufräumt, weil das alles so ein bisschen verspaghettiert hier ist.
Das hier ist, das ist eine, das ist irgendein Reverse-Shell-Versuch, ne?
Das ist, das ist die, das ist diese Bash-Syntax wurde...
Ohne, ohne Netcat und sowas auf, auf Netzwerksachen zugreifen kannst.
Und, ja.
Okay.
Dann ist da nichts dahinter, das ist alles Schein.
Und deshalb bei dieser angeblichen Hospital-Run-Sicherheitslücke...
Hacking-Exploit von Chat-GPT generiert.
Würde ich wirklich mit voller Überzeugung sagen, das ist falsch, das ist nicht richtig.
Und jetzt die große Frage und die kann man sich am Ende vom Video dann auch stellen.
Macht das John Pereira?
Absichtlich?
Versucht er absichtlich hier irgendwie zu täuschen und zu verschleiern und sich einen Wettbewerbsvorteil zu verschaffen gegenüber Firmen, weil das einen guten Werbeeffekt hat?
Also macht, ist da Absicht dahinter?
Oder fehlt ihm so ein bisschen die gewisse realistische Einschätzung, weil das...
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich beides.
Wahrscheinlich beides.
Wahrscheinlich hält er sich für den überkrassen Hackerman, aber in der heutigen Zeit, siehst du das ja auch an, komm in die Gruppe, wir zeigen dir krasses Business, es mehr scheint als sein, scheint sich heute finanziell ja zu lohnen.
Das ist ja auch typisch, man freut sich so sehr über Sicherheitslücken und das ist ein geiles Gefühl, das kann ich verstehen, dass man dann so ein bisschen die Severity, also den Insekt und die Schlimm...
Die krasseste Sicherheitslücke, die ich rausgefunden habe jemals, und ich bin ja nicht im Security-Bereich irgendwie tätig, war, dass man relativ easy aus einer Kamera, also aus einer WiFi-Kamera, das Root-Passwort auslesen kann mit, ja, paar Curl-Aufrufen.
Eigentlich super, super easy.
Das ist einfach nur...
Passende Endpunkte gehen für On-Fifth-Device-Discovery und dann kriegt man das Root-Passwort raus.
Das habe ich an den Hersteller geschrieben und das Erste, was dem Hersteller eingefallen ist, also ich habe ihm ein Beispiel geschickt, wie das geht, und das Erste, was er gemeint hat, ist, ja, mach doch mal ein Firmware-Update oder irgendwie sowas.
Und ich habe gesagt, hä? Also erstens habe ich die aktuelle Firma und was wollt ihr damit?
Dann habe ich nochmal gesagt, Leute, bekommt das Root-Passwort von dem Gerät raus und, ich meine, ich hatte die aktuellste Firmware ja schon, bekommt das Root-Passwort vom Gerät raus, ich habe nicht richtig verstanden, was ich euch geschrieben habe.
Und danach hat es irgendjemand mal gelesen, der es verstanden hat und hat gemeint, oh, ja, das ist tatsächlich ein Problem und ob ich doch bitte mein Beispiel-GitHub-Dokument löschen könnte.
Das war das erste Problem, was er hatte.
Ich habe ihm dann anlistet, GitHub.
Ich habe ihm dann anliste gepostet, wo ich halt geschrieben habe, wie das funktioniert und ob ich nicht den GitHub-Link löschen könnte, GitHub löschen könnte, ja.
Das war das größte Problem, was sie hatten.
Aber tatsächlich ein halbes Jahr später oder so, habe ich eine Benachrichtigung bekommen, dass jetzt eine neue Firmware-Version raus ist, die angeblich alles behebt.
Nun gut. Immerhin.
Eine Sicherheitslücke.
Eine Sicherheitslücke ist so ein bisschen overhyped und man sagt so, oh, das ist voll krass, aber in der Realität ist das nicht ganz so krass.
Und es kann natürlich auch sein, dass er einfach so ein bisschen overhyped ist und ein bisschen falsch interpretiert.
Aber es fehlt halt auch so ein bisschen die gewisse Reflexion.
Hast du das nochmal getestet? Nein.
Ich habe danach die Kamera nie wieder angeschlossen.
Er hat ganz viele negative Kommentare bekommen.
Die wurden alle gelöscht und auch geblockt und ich wurde auch geblockt, weil ich drunter kommentiert habe.
Dann ist das wohl nicht nur, er findet sich als richtig krasser geiler Hackerman.
Sondern es ist auch ein bisschen ein System dahinter.
Wie gesagt, man kann heutzutage mit mehr Schein als Sein durchaus Geld verdienen.
Guckt euch die ganzen, ich zeige euch, wie man krasses Business macht, komm in die Gruppe, Leute, an.
Da geht es auch nur darum, möglichst überzeugend zu wirken für Leute, die halt keinen Plan haben und sich von sowas einfach einwickeln lassen.
Wäre doch ein gutes YouTube-Video-Live-Projekt für dich.
Was denn? Die Kamera nochmal anschließen.
Naja, so spannend ist das jetzt nicht.
Schließ die Kamera an.
Mach zwei Curl-Aufrufe.
Update eine Firmware, mach die Curl-Aufrufe nochmal und dann...
Also, er hält sich doch stark in Grenzen, oder?
Nido, danke schön für den Sub.
Er lässt also überhaupt keine Reflexion zu und er lässt überhaupt keine anderen Professionellen wie uns zu, irgendwie da unsere Meinung zu sagen und ihm zu sagen, hey, das stimmt aber da nicht, was ist da los?
Weil an sich ist es auch ja kein Problem, das quasi zurückzuziehen und zu sagen, ey, sorry, ich hab da einen Fehler gemacht oder sowas.
Müsst ihr ja nicht mehr öffentlich machen, löscht es einfach.
Weißt du, wenn es ein bisschen... Ich verstehe, es ist ein bisschen peinlich und so, aber löscht einfach so, wir vergessen das auch.
McFly, danke für den Sub.
Jetzt aber genug von Hospital Run, lass uns mal noch ein zweites Statement, was er im Interview gesagt hat, ein bisschen genauer drauf schauen.
Also, ich hab Sicherheitslücken bei Google aufgedeckt, bei Microsoft, bei Apple, bei Nokia, bei Siemens, beim Frauenhofer-Institut, bei...
Okay, das, was ich jetzt sage, klingt vielleicht irgendwie gemein und man kann sich den Leuten natürlich auch irren.
Und ich kann euch auch nicht sagen, woran ich es genau festmache.
Aber die ganze Art, über den Sachverhalt zu sprechen, klingt für mich nicht nach Kompetenz.
Ich kann es schlecht beschreiben.
Die Art, wie er das sagt, die Sache, wie das vorgetragen wird, auch wenig detailliert, ich weiß nicht, das wirkt auf mich eher, komm in die Gruppe.
Was einen Deutschen machen.
Pseudo-Experte, das trifft es ganz gut, genau so wirkt das, ja.
Ich kann, mir fällt es immer schwer.
Wenn man, wenn man das so empfindet, das festzumachen an konkreten Sachen, aber so wirkt das auf mich.
Und bei vielen weiteren Unternehmen.
Ich habe zum Beispiel damals die Sicherheitslücke in der Software Apple Motion aufgedeckt.
Das ist eine Software, die 2004 von Apple entwickelt wurde.
Das heißt, die ist schon sehr lange auf dem Markt.
Da haben sehr viele Hacker auch von Apple sich daran ausgetestet und versucht, das Ding wirklich sicher zu machen.
Und da habe ich halt eine Sicherheitslücke gefunden, die ich dann auch in gemeinsamer Zusammenarbeit mit Apple behoben habe, die es mir ermöglicht hat, auf Millionen von Geräten zuzugreifen.
Auf denen diese Software erst erledigt ist.
Was bekommst du da?
Davon hätte man sicherlich mal irgendwie was mitgekriegt, oder?
Es hätte ja irgendwann mal gepatcht werden müssen dann auch.
Also Jean Perrier sagt, er hat eine Sicherheitslücke in der Software gefunden, die heißt Motion von Apple.
Und da sind zwei Claims drin.
Und der erste Claim ist, dass viele Apple Entwickler versucht haben, da schon Sicherheitslücken zu finden und die haben das nicht geschafft.
Aber er hat das geschafft.
Da würde ich sagen, das entspricht nicht ganz so der Realität.
Es stimmt schon, dass solche großen Firmen haben schon Security Teams und die schauen schon einmal nach.
Security Issues.
Aber es ist nicht so, dass die sich da irgendwie Monate oder Jahre lang hinsetzen und nach Sicherheitslücken suchen.
Klingt logisch.
Und jetzt kommt Jean Perrier und findet da was.
Es ist auch wirklich realistisch anzunehmen, dass da nie ein Apple Security Engineer draufgeguckt hat.
Es ist halt auch die Frage, wie relevant die Software ist, um die es hier geht.
Also ich gehe ganz stark davon aus, dass sich diese Apple Teams, je nachdem wie wichtig diese Software ist, um wichtigere Sachen kümmern müssen.
Als irgend so ein Ding, was eh recht unbequem ist.
Recht unbedeutend, unkritisch ist.
Ja, wenn da irgendwie einer Kerneländerungen eincheckt, im Apple Shit, dann...
Also wenn da irgendein Commit macht mit Kerneländerungen, dass da mal ein Security Team draufguckt, ist wahrscheinlicher.
Weil das an sich nicht ganz so spannend ist.
Diese Security Engineers von Apple, die beschäftigen sich eher so mit iOS im Gesamten und so.
Und da haben sie genug zu tun.
Und da machen sie auch richtig gute Arbeit.
Und ich kann das jetzt nicht beweisen.
Und ich kenne auch, glaube ich, niemanden bei Apple, der da zu der Zeit gearbeitet hat, der mir das beantworten könnte, ob da Security Leute draufgeguckt haben.
Und der würde das wahrscheinlich eh mir nicht öffentlich sagen und so.
Aber der Claim ist so, muss man das sagen.
Ich meine, er kann es auch nicht beweisen.
Und jetzt der zweite Claim, da da ja quasi gesagt wird, er hat eine Sicherheitslücke in Motion gefunden.
Und da könnte er Millionen von Leuten damit hacken und so.
Die es mir ermöglicht hat, auf Millionen von Geräten zuzugreifen, auf denen diese Software installiert ist.
Da fehlen einfach irgendwie die Details.
Wenn das jemand wirklich...
Ich weiß nicht.
Also mal angenommen.
Natürlich sind Leute immer ein bisschen anders.
Aber mal angenommen, man hätte da wirklich was gefunden, was das ermöglicht.
Irgendwie hätte ich das ein bisschen fundierter erzählt einfach, wenn da wirklich was dran gewesen wäre.
Ja, da würdest du erzählen.
Und wir haben wochenlang, haben wir hier was analysiert.
Und irgendwann ist uns dann wirklich im Netzwerk Traffic was aufgefallen, was verschlüsselt war, aber was irgendwie nicht richtig implementiert gewesen ist.
Irgendwie ein bisschen mehr Kontext.
Klar.
Und dann kannst du jetzt sagen, okay, dieses Interview richtet sich vielleicht nicht an die super krassen Fachmänner, was auch immer.
Aber so ein bisschen Substanz.
Und das ist ein Ding, was mir bei vielen Leuten, die einfach nur schwätzen und keine Ahnung haben, auffällt.
Die erzählen immer viel, aber es hat immer relativ wenig Substanz drinne.
Wo du immer sagen würdest, das bewegt sich alles immer so im Allgemeinen ein bisschen abstrakten und wenig Substanz drinne.
Wo du sagen könntest, okay, was war denn jetzt eigentlich?
Also die erste Frage, hat der wirklich einen Security?
Es hat wirklich ein bisschen was von komm in die Gruppe, genau.
Ja, schon gefunden.
Und da der Plot Twist, ja, ich glaube schon.
Also das liest sich erstmal hier total legit und das ist auch auf der Apple Report Seite und so weiter.
Und da steht auch dran, die CVE-2013-6114 von Jean-Pascal Pereira.
A maliciously crafted MOTN-File could lead to arbitrary code execution.
Das sieht schon total legit aus.
Und er hat auch Details über diese Vulnerability hier veröffentlicht.
Hat er hier auch gepublished, 2013.
Und da sieht man die kleine Testdatei, mit dem er das triggern kann.
Und da drüber sieht man die Debug-Message.
Wo ich dann auch sehen kann, okay, das sieht legit aus.
Also da hat das Register RAX, hat einen bestimmten Wert.
Dieser Wert ist genau der Wert in dem Subview.
Das ist irgendwie so ein bisschen weird, aber kann schon sein.
Dieses RAX-Register wurde als ein Offset benutzt, in ein Array oder sowas.
Und es hat dann out of bounds einfach in Memory irgendwo gezeigt, weil die Zahl so riesig war,
dass es dann eine invalide Adresse war und das ist dann gecrashed.
Man muss aber dazu auch sagen, dass das nur ein Proof of Concept ist.
Das ist also nur eine kleine Datei, die total minimalistisch ist, die nur diesen Bug triggert.
Den jetzt ausnutzen und daraus jetzt einen vollwertigen Exploit bauen,
also mit allem drum und dran, dass wenn man die Datei öffnet, dass dann irgendwas installiert wird und so,
das erfordert dann nochmal richtig viel Arbeit.
Und es kann auch sein, dass dieser Bug gar nicht exploitbar ist.
Also wenn man sich dann richtig ransetzt und versucht, das zu entwickeln und so,
dann kann sein, dass man in so Edge-Cases reinrennt und merkt,
ja, der Bug ist zwar irgendwie ein kleines Problem im Code und so und sollte auf jeden Fall gefixt werden,
aber jetzt so ein vollwertiger Exploit lässt sich daraus nicht bauen.
Er kommt nicht weiter.
Das liegt vor allem daran, weil die Zeile, die crasht, ist ein Read.
Also es versucht von einem invaliden Memory was zu lesen.
Das lässt sich aber so nicht unbedingt beurteilen.
Und grundsätzlich ist es auch immer nervig zu sagen so,
hey, das ist ja nur ein Proof of Concept, mach mal ein vollwertiges Exploit, sonst glaube ich dir nicht.
Es ist einfach gut anzunehmen, so ein Crash ist exploitbar, muss gefixt werden und dafür gibt es auch Credits.
Also das ist wirklich ein legit Exploit.
Und lasst mich das mal einordnen.
Das war 2013. Da habe ich so, war ich so ein Jahr lang oder so in IT Security.
Hätte ich so einen Bug gefunden, ich wäre aus dem Häuschen.
Das ist wirklich ein cooler Bug.
Das ist ein Bug, wo ich sagen würde, ja, die Person versteht Hacking.
Die hat ein gewisses technisches Grundverständnis und hat eine CVE dafür bekommen und so weiter.
Und ich wäre wirklich, wirklich stolz.
Und da kann auch Jean Pereira stolz drauf sein.
Ich hätte das, und das kann ich mit voller Überzeugung sagen, nicht finden können damals.
Also dafür kann er wirklich Respekt bekommen.
Aber er sagt, damit hätte er Millionen von Leuten hacken können.
Aber wenn wir nochmal uns die Beschreibung hier durchlesen.
Es geht darum, dass diese Sicherheitslücke ausgenutzt wird, wenn man mit Motion diese böse MOTN Datei öffnet.
Und damit sollte eigentlich...
Genau. Die Leute müssen das Zeug erstmal, was auch immer eine Modendatei ist, die müssen die Datei erstmal irgendwie bekommen und irgendwie ausführen.
Das ist ja das, was ich auch schon oft gesagt habe.
Und da sage ich jetzt jemand, der nicht irgendwie großartig im Security Sektor unterwegs ist.
Aber ich würde mal behaupten, das ist so Allgemeinkenntnis von Leuten, die ein bisschen IT Ahnung haben.
Das Schwierige ist gar nicht so sehr.
Oder nicht primär, dass du irgendwie irgendein Virus oder irgendeine malwareverseuchte Datei auf den Rechner von einem drauf bekommst.
Das ist das eine.
Dass die ausgeführt wird.
Dass das aktiv wird, was da drin ist.
Das ist ja das eigentlich Schwierige.
Eine E-Mail schicken mit einem Virus als Anhang.
Das kann jeder.
Aber dass das ausgeführt wird.
Ich meine, das ist das, wo die ganzen Scammer und die ganzen Leute...
Die ganzen Leute, die irgendwie versuchen, irgendwas unterzuschieben.
Wo die sehr viel Energie und Hirnschmalz reinstecken.
Dass die Leute nicht nur die Datei dann in ihrem E-Mail-Postfach liegen haben oder auf ihren Rechner haben.
Sondern nein, dass die die ausführen, indem sie ihnen sonst was erzählen.
Deswegen sind Dateien getarnt als Word-Dokumente.
Aber sie sind in Wirklichkeit Screensafer für Windows, die komische Dinger nachladen.
Alles mögliche.
Einfach nur, damit es vertrauenswürdiger aussieht.
Damit es ausgeführt wird.
Natürlich gibt es dann auch noch so die super Hardcore-Sachen.
Wo beispielsweise diese...
Erinnert sich noch einer an diese Thumbnail-Lücke im Windows Explorer?
Wo manipulierte Dateien, manipulierte Bilddateien durch das pure Öffnen des Verzeichnisses Teile in der Datei ausgeführt wurden.
Weil der Windows Explorer Thumbnails generieren wollte für die Datei.
Und das dann irgendwie ausnutzbar war, dieses Verhalten.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie das genau gewesen ist.
Das ist natürlich dann richtig für den Arsch.
Dann musst du eine Datei runterladen und nur in das Verzeichnis gehen und schon hast du dir was eingefangen.
Aber das ist ja glücklicherweise, normalerweise ist das ja nicht der Fall.
Du bekommst was, du musst es aktiv ausführen.
In irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Oder du gehst mit einem Browser auf die Datei, mit einem alten Browser, mit Sicherheitslücken.
Aber irgendwie musst du es nicht nur bekommen, irgendwie muss es ausgeführt werden.
Oftmals mit Zutun der Leute selbst.
Und das ist tatsächlich das Schwierige.
Es muss schon klar sein, dass du nicht einfach Millionen von Apple-Usern hacken kannst.
Sondern du musst irgendwie die Leute dazu bringen, dass sie diese Datei erstmal öffnen.
Chat, genau.
Das ist relativ selten.
Der meiste Scam passiert dadurch, dass irgendwie einer auch heutzutage noch einen E-Mail-Anhang bekommt.
Die Sekretärin bekommt eine E-Mail, vermeintlich Absender vom Chef aus, von der Geschäftsreise.
E-Mail mit dem Anhang, bitte schnellstens drum kümmern.
Und keinem was erzählen, streng geheim.
Bitte schnellstens drum kümmern.
Und diese Sachen hier in diesem Word-Dokument erledigen.
Ja.
So, und dann denkt die sich, oh ne, der Chef im Geschäft ist ganz, ganz wichtig.
Und auch keinem erzählen, geht hier um Leben und Tod.
So nach dem Motto, öffnet die Word-Datei.
Und die haben vielleicht noch irgendwie ein olles Word.
Was anfällig ist für irgendwas.
Und zack, bumm.
Haben die sich irgendwas eingefangen.
Äh, Fileserver der ganzen Firma encrypted und Lösegeldforderung.
Ja, zack.
Das geht dann zackig.
So, es braucht in, sag mal, im riesengroßen überwiegenden Teil der Fälle, braucht es halt noch das Zutun von irgendjemand.
So dieses reine, den Rechner mal anhusten mit irgendeinem Virus.
Und schon, schon haddern.
Ist halt nicht.
So das mit Thumbnail-Generierung war wirklich, war wirklich Ausnahme.
Die, die, die Ausnahme, ja.
Und glücklicherweise haben wir so Sachen wie Hardbleed und sowas auch nicht ganz so oft.
Du könntest irgendwie deinen Freund hacken oder so.
Wenn du dem ne Mail schreibst, hey, schau dir mal diese File an.
Oder du könntest jetzt so ein Download anbieten in nem Forum oder sowas.
Und dann lädt sie jemand runter.
Dann könnt ihr gehackt werden und so.
Ja, also dafür, genau dafür ist es machbar.
Aber da kommen wir jetzt halt wieder zu diesen.
Zu diesen bisschen übertriebenen Claims.
Ja.
Zu sagen einfach, damit kann man Millionen von Apple-Usern hacken oder sowas.
Das ist meiner Meinung nach falsch.
Und das ist halt das, was ein bisschen weird ist mit Jean Pereira.
Auf der einen Seite, das ist meiner Meinung nach wirklich ein legit exploit.
Das ist nicht fake.
Und das ist wirklich cool.
Da kann man stolz drauf sein.
Und ich finde auch, da kann er wirklich mit prahlen, dass er das gefunden hat.
Aber ich finde es dann so extrem unnötig, irgendwie das zu overhypen und zu claimen.
Damit könnte man Millionen von Leuten hacken.
Ja.
Ja, könnte man.
Das ist.
Und das ist dieser Comedy-Gruppe-Faktor, den ich da am Anfang schon verspürt hab.
Ja.
Na, mal gucken.
Von Millionen von Leuten schlagen.
Aber da müsste ich zu Millionen von Leuten hinlaufen und denen ins Gesicht schlagen.
Weißt du, also das.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der Vergleich jetzt so gut war, aber erstmal Schluck Mate.
Also, wir haben uns jetzt zwei Claims angeschaut in diesem 30-Minuten-Interview.
Und diese Claims waren wirklich nur kurze Sätze.
So ein, zwei Sätze, die er gesagt hat.
Und die erfordern richtig viel Wissen und Erfahrung, um das richtig einordnen zu können.
So ein Standard-Informatik-Student an der Uni, der eigentlich schon gut ausgebildet
ist, der wird das nicht mal richtig einschätzen können.
Und deshalb würde ich auch sagen, Leeroy trifft in dem Fall jetzt keine Schuld, weil
von außen sieht das alles erstmal alles irgendwie okay aus.
Und man muss da schon tief drin sein.
Nein, wir haben noch nicht den Wahl-O-Mat gemacht.
Stimmt, das müssten wir eigentlich auch mal machen.
Wann ist denn in Hessen?
Ist es nächste Woche?
Am 8.
Ja, nächsten.
Das machen wir, das machen wir dann nächste Woche.
Also nicht, vielleicht nicht Sonntagmorgen.
Irgendwann nächste Woche.
Unter der Woche.
Weil ich das dann gestern gesehen hab.
Vor allem haben wir andere coole deutsche Hacker, die man da einladen könnte.
Und das hat mich dann irgendwie so ein bisschen so getriggert, dass ich dann so ein bisschen
mehr recherchiert habe, was hat Jean Pereira eigentlich noch so gemacht.
Und da bin ich dann über diesen Talk hier gestoßen, wo er über Browser-Exploitation
redet.
Und da introduced er seinen Bamboo-JS-Fuzzer.
Aber schau mal das passende Hoodie an.
Ich bin ja nicht so drin in der ganzen Hackerman-Geschichte.
Ist ein Fuzzer nicht diese Geschichte?
Die einfach ganz viele random generated Inputs an Programme schickt in der Hoffnung, das
verhält sich irgendwie merkwürdig.
Also wo du ganz, ganz viel random Krams einfach durchtesten kannst.
Ich glaube schon.
Wörter, die so ein normaler Zuschauer wahrscheinlich nicht versteht.
Also ein Fuzzer ist ein Programm, mit dem man einfach zufällig was generiert und hofft,
dass durch diese zufällig generierte Zeug irgendwie das Programm crasht oder kaputt
geht oder sowas.
Und wenn man dann sowas gefunden hat.
So ein Crash ist oft ein Indikator, dass da vielleicht eine Sicherheitslücke sein könnte.
Gerade im Browser.
Das heißt, im Falle von Browsern zum Beispiel generiert man einfach irgendwie zufälligen
Javascript oder zufälligen HTML-Code und hofft, dass der Browser dann crasht.
Und dann kann man das vielleicht exploiten.
Und man kann da so einen Drive-by-Exploit quasi daraus bauen, dass wenn man dann auf
eine Webseite geht, dass man dann...
Das ist natürlich das Heftigste, was dir als Browser-Hersteller, generell als User
auch passieren kann.
Durch das pure Besuchen einer Internetseite dazu führt, dass du dir irgendwelche E-Mail-Mail
einfängst.
Das ist doch in den letzten Jahren, finde ich, relativ selten geworden.
Gerade wenn man sowas wie NoScript bzw.
uBlock oder sowas noch zusätzlich verwendet, dass einige Sachen gar nicht erst nachgeladen
werden.
Das ist relativ selten geworden.
Meinem Eindruck nachher.
Und das ist besonders beeindruckend, wenn man sich überlegt, dass Browser heutzutage
mehr verwendet werden als jemals zuvor.
Also die Browser-Verwendung hat ja extrem zugenommen.
Viele Leute benutzen heute ein Browser.
Die verwenden im Prinzip...
Guck mal.
Ich meine, ich habe nur Browser auf.
Kaum noch andere Anwendungen.
Browser.
Alles in Browsern.
Allein schon, dass das heute eines der meistverwendeten Programme überhaupt ist.
Browser.
Sowohl im Mobile als auch auf dem Desktop.
Egal, wo.
Auf dem Fernseher vielleicht nicht.
Aber überall.
Und dass ein Browser per Design eigentlich ein Stück Software ist, was im Vergleich
zu vielen anderen...
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nichtbl благодарungslos zu sagen, dass die語 Schcamera da unten
machlagend 1997 im mit AGC den continentschart, die mit deusse
also es ist es ist enorm selten deswegen browser aktuell halten richtig natürlich noch besser du
hast einen aktuellen browser unter einer linux vm oder unter dem linux selbst wenn du dir dann
drive bei was einfängst geht es dann spätestens an der stelle wahrscheinlich nicht weiter muss
ja muss ja wie funktioniert das genau das hängt von der von der jeweiligen sicherheitslücke ab
was man da genau machen muss vielleicht kannst du aus der javascript sandbox ausbrechen wenn
du aus der javascript sandbox ausbrechen kannst dann kannst du natürlich auch aufs lokale datei
system zugreifen und es braucht ja immer mehrere stufen als erstes musst du denjenigen erstmal auf
deine seite bekommen dann musst du eine sicherheitslücke die sonst noch keiner gefunden
hat haben oder die zumindest die browser hersteller noch nicht kennen sicherheitslücke
haben um beispielsweise javascript auszuführen der aus der sandbox ausbrechen kann dann muss
dieser sandbox escape wie auch immer das genau
richtig nennt sich dafür eignen dass du lokal nicht nur ja auch fall system zugreifen kann
das allein wird ja eventuell noch gar nicht so viel bringen das so lokal vielleicht sagen
starten kann ja dass rausfällt system zugreifen kann und sac chan starten so da kannst du zumindest
schon mal im user kontext alles machen und dann brauchst du noch irgendein betriebssystem export
Der noch nicht gefixt ist, um Root oder Admin zu werden. Wobei du auch schon im User-Kontext genug machen kannst. Ja, also diese ganzen, diese ganzen hier, ich habe dein YouTube-Account gehackt, Geschichten, die in letzter Zeit passiert sind, das braucht ja keine Root-Rechte in dem Sinn.
Das hat Session-Daten kopiert aus dem Browser und das geht, das reicht, wenn das im User-Kontext läuft. Das ist glücklicherweise ziemlich schwierig und dadurch, dass es, in dem Fall ist es sogar ganz gut, dass es nicht so viele Browser-Engines gibt und auch nicht so viele JavaScript, also nicht so viele JavaScript-Engines, weil gerade V8 ist doch ziemlich gut testet mittlerweile.
Und nicht nur in Browsern, auch mit Netzwerken.
Ich habe vergessen, wie heißt die Mozilla-JavaScript-Engine? Monkey irgendwas, oder? Weiß das einer von euch aus dem Kopf? Monkey, ne, wie heißt denn das? Firefox, Spider-Monkey, Spider-Monkey, ja, genau.
Ja, das, das meine ich. Und, ja, aber es ist beides V8.
Oder? Chatge? Ne, Deno ist auch V8. Bun ist irgendwas anderes. Bun ist, auf was, auf was basiert, ah, nein, die benutzen JavaScript-Core, das ist, ist das vom Webkit? Das ist Webkit, ja, genau.
Ja, okay, gucken wir mal weiter.
Die Einschätzung 2022, 2023, die Browser sind grundsätzlich so sicher, dass ihr da keine Sorgen mehr haben müsst. Früher war das so, dass wirklich Exploits so verbreitet waren, dass du wirklich auf eine Webseite gegangen bist und hast den Virus eingefangen. Das ist heutzutage eigentlich nicht mehr so. Das liegt daran, weil die Browser schon so sicher sind.
Ich erstelle auf der Arbeit keine, ich bin kein hauptberuflicher Softwareentwickler. Ich kümmere mich hauptsächlich aktuell um Cloud-Infrastruktur.
... sind, dass diese Exploits extrem teuer sind. Also da gibt es richtig...
... richtig, richtig viel Geld dafür und es ist schon kompliziert, so einen Exploit zu bauen. Deswegen, die Kunden von sowas sind eher so Government Agencies oder sowas, die irgendjemanden halt hacken wollen für Intelligence Agencies Sachen und so halt. Ich habe dazu übrigens auch ein Video auf dem Hype-Kanal, wo ich so ein bisschen auf das Thema eingehe, ob jedes Device gehackt werden kann oder so.
Ja, prinzipiell, also meiner Meinung dazu ist, in das Video von ihm jetzt dazu nicht, meiner Meinung nach, dass du in der Theorie wahrscheinlich jedes Gerät hacken kannst, in der Praxis nicht.
Weil in der Theorie geht das ja allein schon, guck mal, theoretisch könntest du sagen, ja, du kannst theoretisch auch jedes Passwortbrut forcen.
Wenn du ein paar Billionen Jahre Zeit hast und wir meinen jetzt nicht die Ami-Billion, sondern unsere Billion, dann ja, oder wenn du nahezu unendlich viel Geld hast, in der Regel ist es ja meistens eine Kombination aus, lohnt es sich?
Das ist ja generell eine Frage.
Das ist eine Frage, die man sich bei vielem stellen muss, lohnt es sich?
So, und wenn im Endeffekt der Kostenaufwand das, was man abstauben kann, übersteigt, dann wird das in der Praxis wahrscheinlich nicht passieren.
Und da rede ich mit Security-Researchern, mit Leuten, die wirklich solche Exploits gefunden haben, nachweislich, und hab die einfach mal so gefragt und einschätzen lassen, so wie das Risiko ist mit Browsern und so weiter.
Also wenn euch das interessiert, dann guckt euch das auf jeden Fall an.
Und deswegen wurde ich hier halt so ein bisschen hellhörig, weil das ist schon Top-Tier-Level-Hacking.
Exploitation und Browser-Fuzzing und so weiter.
Und John Pereira sagt, er hat einen Fuzzer geschrieben, Bamboo.js, den gibt's auch auf GitHub.
Und so ein Basic-Fuzzer-Schreiben ist an sich erstmal nicht schwierig, du musst halt einfach nur so random Code generieren lassen.
Die Frage ist halt, ob so ein Fuzzer dann auch was findet.
Und mein erster Eindruck von diesem Code ist einfach, der ist wirklich wenig, da ist einfach wenig Code da.
Und das heißt nicht, dass dieser Fuzzer nichts finden kann.
Das kann ich jetzt nicht beweisen, dass dieser Fuzzer nichts finden kann.
Man kann so dieses Negativ halt nicht beweisen.
Ich kann nicht beweisen, dass dieser Fuzzer jetzt nichts gefunden hat.
Wenn das ein wirklich beliebter, guter Fuzzer wäre, dann wäre das nicht letztes Commit vor 10 Jahren und kaum Source-Code, keine Issues und nix und keine Sterne.
Schon sein.
Aber wenn man das eben vergleicht mit richtigen Fuzzern, was so moderne Fuzzer wirklich machen, das ist eine hochkomplexe Software, wo wirklich, da steckt monatelange Arbeit drin.
Das ist richtig krasses Engineering kombiniert mit Hacking-Wissen.
Das ist wirklich unik, da bist du wirklich Top-Tier.
Und dieser Code, der sieht halt einfach nicht danach aus.
Aber wie gesagt, man kann das negativ.
Man kann das negativ halt nicht so beweisen, dass ob dieser Fuzzer wirklich was gefunden hat.
Lass uns mal kurz gucken.
Ist Bamboo nicht der Jetbrains Jenkins Abklatsch?
Das ist nicht auch so.
Okay, lass uns mal kurz gucken.
Wie heißt das?
GitHub Bamboo.
Ja.
Okay, 56 Sterne.
Da hat er sogar White People Happy Background mehr Sterne.
Gut, Sterne sind nicht unbedingt.
Aber, sondern nicht beliebt, kann das jetzt ja nicht sein.
2013, ein Example Code, und es ist allgemein, ich mein, da ist ja nichts drin.
Das sind insgesamt, was weiß ich, 600 Zeilen JavaScript und irgendein Ruby, Ruby Backend oder was auch immer.
Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass das irgendwie super krasser Ackerman-Shit ist.
Aber jetzt hört mal zu, was er hier in diesem Talk sagt.
I just realized that it can find vulnerabilities in every browser.
So it can find vulnerabilities in Safari, Chrome and Firefox and Internet Explorer.
And these vulnerabilities have been actually reported and stated as CVE.
So all these vulnerabilities have been found with Bamboo.js, with the fuzzer.
Man muss hier wirklich ein bisschen aufpassen auf seine Wortwahl.
Er sagt hier, all these issues have been found oder could be found, ist ein bisschen schwierig zu interpretieren.
Also mein Eindruck war jedenfalls, dass er claimed, dass sein fuzzer Bamboo.js,
drei Sicherheitsmöglichkeiten,
drei Sicherheitslücken gefunden hat in Safari, Chrome und Firefox.
Jedenfalls auf der Slide steht auch, it revealed, also dieser Fuzzer hat das gefunden.
Und dann bin ich jetzt einfach mal hingegangen und hab einfach mal diese CVEs nachgeguckt.
Die erste CVE hier in Internet Explorer, eine Memory Corruption Vulnerability, sieht legit aus,
aber die ist gecredited zu Zheng Guang of Baidu's S-Cloud X Team, working with HP's Zero-Day Initiative.
Das wurde also reported von einem chinesischen Hacker, Teil des Baidus Security Teams,
beziehungsweise reported über HP.
HP's Zero-Day Initiative, also HP hat eine Zero-Day Initiative, wo sie, glaube ich, quasi diesen Researchern Geld bezahlt.
Und dann HP hat das reported zu Microsoft.
Das ist alles so ein bisschen weird, wie das in der Hacking-Welt manchmal so funktioniert und so.
Aber hier steht nicht, dass John Pereira das gefunden hat.
Die nächste CVE betrifft Safari.
Und auch hier wieder ist jemand anders gecredited.
Hier steht, dass Tencent, es tut mir so leid, ich kann das nicht aussprechen,
Zhongon Xin, Ling Chen, Feng Wuxi.
Tut mir leid, dass ich nicht weiß, wie man das ausspricht.
Aber Tencent kennt ihr wahrscheinlich, ist eine massiv große Firma und KeenLab ist bekannt in der Hacking-Szene.
Das KeenLab Security Team ist wirklich top Tier in der Welt, wirklich top, top Level Security Researchers.
Und die sind hier gecredited, dass die das gefunden haben.
Und hier ist die Firefox-Sicherheitslücke, eine Use After Free.
Und der Credit ist hier gegeben zu Echo.
Das ist also jetzt ein Pseudonym.
Da könnte natürlich John Pereira dahinter stecken.
Ich sage jetzt einfach mal, ich habe den Namen in Verbindung mit John Pereira noch nicht gehört.
Ich habe den Namen in Verbindung mit John Pereira noch nicht gehört.
Ich würde jetzt einfach mal behaupten, dass es auch nicht John Pereira, aber könnte natürlich sein.
Das heißt, all diese 3 CVEs wurden nicht von ihm reported,
aber das Ding ist, er hat ja auch nicht geclaimed, dass er die reported hat,
sondern er hat geclaimed, sein Faser hat die gefunden.
Und das kann ich jetzt nicht beweisen, ob quasi diese chinesischen Researchers...
Es wirkt aber trotzdem etwas shady, oder?
Man könnte es ja auch ganz klar sagen, was Sache ist, oder?
Man könnte auch einfach sagen, ja,
Das chinesische Research-Team hat meinen Fuzzer verwendet dafür, um das aufzudecken.
Und Echo, ob die diesen BambooJS-Fuzzer benutzt haben und die gefunden haben.
Meine Einschätzung, einfach mein Bauchgefühl...
Dass sie den nicht verwendet haben.
Ich glaube nicht, dass BambooJS das gefunden hat.
Dieses Browser-Hacking ist einfach eine andere Liga.
Diese chinesischen Security-Researcher, die sind total krank.
Das ist unglaublich.
Und wenn Joe Pereira und sein Fuzzer wirklich so Zeug gefunden hätte,
dann wäre das ein Name, den ich auch wüsste.
Oder ein Name, der bekannt wäre.
Und ein Name, wo die Leute wirklich Respekt davor haben.
Und wahrscheinlich, es kann auch durchaus sein, dass das dann in irgendeiner Beschreibung dazu gestanden hätte.
Zumal, das Guitar-Projekt juckt ja auch niemand.
Das klingt auch sehr shady alles.
Browser-Hacker. Aber das ist so nicht.
Diese Meinung habe ich noch nie irgendwo gehört.
Und das gibt mir dann halt einfach so ein ungutes Bauchgefühl.
Wo ich das Gefühl habe, hm, hat der jetzt...
...nur behauptet, der Bamboo-Fuzzer ist gefunden?
Und das ist wirklich gelogen?
Oder haben die Leute den BambooJS-Fuzzer vielleicht benutzt?
Das kann ich jetzt nicht beweisen.
Es fühlt sich für mich komisch an.
Ich lasse mich da auch gerne eines Besseren belehren.
Also, falls es da eine Correction gibt, dann schaut mal runter in die Kommentare oder in die Beschreibung.
Aber mein erster Eindruck ist so, hm, das wirkt ein bisschen sus.
Okay, so.
Dann habe ich nochmal ein bisschen weiter rumgeschaut.
Und dann bin ich über einen Chrome-Exploit von ihm gestoßen,
der tatsächlich dieses Jahr veröffentlicht wurde.
Und wie ich schon erwähnt habe,
Browser-Exploits in 2023 ist schon richtig krass.
Das ist richtig, wie gesagt, top tier.
Ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen.
Das ist richtig crazy.
Das heißt, da werde ich auf jeden Fall erstmal stutzig, wenn ich das sehe.
Da fangen so direkt meine Fühlerchen an.
Da werde ich erstmal skeptisch und so.
Aber hey, hier ist ein Proof-of-Concept.
Ich kann es testen.
Also habe ich hier sein Skript, das scheinbar die Vulnerability...
Okay, okay, lass mal checken.
Was passiert da?
Web-GPU?
Was?
Bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, ob das überhaupt...
Ist das nicht noch experimental überhaupt?
Na gut, ist ja auch egal.
Das muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Can I use...
Ist aber auch egal.
Das sollte trotzdem ordentlich funktionieren.
Web-GPU...
Ne, guck mal.
Die meisten Browser.
Okay, Chrome hat's...
Not enabled unter Linux by default.
Also hält sich noch sehr in Grenzen.
Also ich glaube, dass das Web-GPU...
Das steht doch auch oben.
Chrome Web-GPU Memory Corruption.
Steht doch sogar oben, Web-GPU.
Okay, irgendwelche Grafik-Zeug...
Gut, da habe ich noch nie was mitgemacht.
Keine Ahnung.
Was macht denn das?
Ist das irgendwie...
Ist das Web-Assembly?
Oder was passiert da?
Oder ist das irgendwie explizit was, um diese Web-GPU...
Keine Ahnung, ich habe mit Web-GPU noch nie was gemacht.
So, Memory Corruption.
Okay, mal gucken, was da draus kommt.
Trigger und Soll genommen, mal runtergeladen und im Browser geöffnet.
Und siehe da, mein Tab crasht.
Eine Webseite, die crasht...
Ja, na gut.
Erst mal so ein Indikator, dass...
Also, man kann übrigens relativ einfach eine Webseite crashen lassen,
wenn das Ding zu viel RAM anfordert oder sowas.
Das habe ich auch schon ein paar Mal.
Wenn ich nicht aufgepasst habe, dann hing es und irgendwann ist es abgekackt.
Also gerade als ich versucht habe,
mit WebRTC für ein paar Kameras mal was zu bauen,
da habe ich es auch manchmal geschafft, dass der Browser-Tab...
Sogar im Stream hat man es gehabt, dass der Browser-Tab den Geist aufgegeben hat.
Und beim einen Mal hatte ich einfach nahezu unendlich Zeug in irgendeinem Array geschrieben
und dann ist es irgendwann auch abgekackt.
Ja.
Und wo wir es auch geschafft haben,
war bei der C++...
WebAssembly-Geschichte.
Da haben wir es, glaube ich, auch mal geschafft,
wo wir diesen FFmpeg,
diesen C++-FFmpeg-Video-Player
gebaut haben im Browser.
Da hatten wir es, glaube ich, auch geschafft,
den Browser zu crashen.
...eine Sicherheitslücke sein könnte.
Es muss nicht.
Es kann auch zum Beispiel sein, dass ihr nicht genug RAM habt
und der Browser sagt, oh mein Gott, du benutzt so viel RAM,
jetzt lass uns mal die Seite crashen
oder da ist ein Endless-Schleif oder sowas
und die Seite hängt und dann...
Das habe ich auch schon.
Das hat jeder wahrscheinlich schon.
Es gibt also viele Cases, wo es nicht ausnutzbar sind.
Aber sagen wir mal so, wenn da eine Sicherheitslücke ist,
dann würde die auch so crashen,
dann würde das erst mal so aussehen.
Und deshalb macht es schon Sinn,
da mal ein bisschen tiefer zu investigaten.
Also ich bin jetzt auch nicht Top-Tier-Browser-Exploitation,
ich kenne mich da auch nicht aus.
Deshalb habe ich einen Kumpel gefragt, Sirius.
Der hat zwar selber auch noch mit Fuzzing keine Wunderbills gefunden.
Reminder, Browser-Sicherheitslücken finden ist richtig crazy,
das ist wirklich Top-Tier-Hacking und so.
Aber was er schon gemacht hat, ist, er hat End Days,
also Sachen, die schon reported wurden, benutzt
und hat daraus dann einen vollen Exploit gebaut.
Also er hat so ein Proof-of-Concept,
so ein minimalistisches Ding, was irgendwie Crash genommen,
und er kann das dann so daraus einen vollen Exploit bauen.
Das ist auch schon technisch richtig krass,
da muss man sich auch richtig auskennen,
wie der Browser intern funktioniert und so,
und ich kann das auch nicht.
Aber deshalb habe ich ihn halt gefragt,
und er hat sich das mal angeguckt.
Und wenn man die Seite halt öffnet
und guckt mal in die Logs, was passiert,
dann sieht man, dass der Tab crasht mit diesem
Check Failed, ist detached.
Und da steht auch dran,
dass das in der Datei gpu-buffer.cc ist.
Und Chromium ist Open Source,
also wir können jetzt in den Quellcode vom Browser gucken
und mal schauen, wieso dieser Fehler passiert ist,
also was ist da passiert.
Und dann findet man hier diese Codezeile mit Check ist detached,
und dieser Check ist ein sogenannter Assert,
dass wenn diese Condition da in diesen Klammern halt...
Okay, das ist ein absichtlicher Crash,
so nach dem Motto, ey, dann stimmt irgendwas nicht,
lass mal lieber crashen, bevor noch was Schlimmeres passiert.
...dann richtig ist, dann sagt der Browser,
oh, da stimmt irgendwas nicht, ich cancel jetzt,
ich crashe jetzt.
Und da ist ein Kommentar auch darüber,
und da steht dran,
Temporary Check to Prevent Alias Array Buffers.
Und da ist auch ein Chrome-Bug verlinkt,
das heißt, dieser Chrome-Bug ist der Grund,
wieso dieser Check da drin ist.
Und den können wir uns jetzt mal angucken,
weil das ist auch öffentlich.
Und hier sehen wir jetzt, dass dieses Issue,
dieser Use After Free in WebGPU,
wurde reported in Mai 2022 von David Manu Jeheri.
Und der hat auch hier ein Proof-of-Concept-Exploit attached,
also wieder ein bisschen Code, der das halt exploitet.
Und da sehen wir auch, das ist komplett legit.
Da siehst du, da kann man die Kommentare lesen
von den Entwicklern von Google,
oder Chromium halt,
die halt dann sich den Exploit angucken
und überlegen, wie da gefixt werden kann.
Und am Ende kommt halt dann der Fix raus.
Und man sieht dann auch hier,
das ist ein Reward von 10.000 Dollar.
Also die Person für den Report hat halt 10.000 Dollar bekommen.
Und jetzt kann man sich auch diesen Exploit-Code angucken,
und man sieht so, der ist auch schon ein bisschen länger.
Also der ist ein bisschen länger als das,
was Jean Pereira gezeigt hat.
Aber das kann auch Sinn machen,
weil ein Use After Free, das ist so eine gewisse Sicherheits-,
ich weiß auch nicht so richtig, wie ich das beschreiben soll,
aber ein Use After Free ist ein bisschen eine
weirde Sicherheitslücke.
Die ist auch ein bisschen schwierig,
immer herauszufinden, was so der,
die Quelle der Sicherheitslücke ist und so,
weil oft quasi der Crash,
also das Symptom der Sicherheitslücke später zu sehen ist,
aber früher in der Ausführung ist,
irgendwas passiert, was später dazu geführt hat.
Und dann zu verstehen, dass das hier am Anfang dazu führt,
dass später das passiert,
das ist immer so ein bisschen weird und so.
Und deshalb ist das...
Und Use After Free ist ja,
also wenn man das jetzt mal, was weiß ich,
gucken wir mal irgendwie,
bei C++ oder in C ist es ja relativ einfach,
du legst, erstellst irgendeinen Pointer,
so,
dann machst du ein Free drauf,
aber du hast ja immer noch die Variable,
wo die Adresse quasi von dem Pointer drinsteht
und du greifst dann später drauf zu,
obwohl du vorher schon ein Free hast.
Dann greifst du,
das ist halt undefiniert, was dann da rauskommt.
Generell ist in C,
leider auch in C++,
sehr viel undefiniert.
Vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Code notwendig,
um Reliable quasi so einen Ablauf zu haben.
Das kann dir höchstwahrscheinlich in Rust nicht passieren,
für die ganzen Krustentiere unter uns.
Ich meine, in Rust kann es dir mit Unsafe definitiv passieren
und wahrscheinlich,
wenn du ganz abgedrehte Sachen machst,
wo der Borrow Checker nicht mehr hinterherkommt,
vielleicht auch,
aber zumindest den Großteil der Fälle
sollte Rust abfangen für sowas.
Führ das aus und dann wird das getriggert
und dann siehst du, dass das wirklich passiert und so.
Weil manchmal, weiß nicht,
ich weiß nicht, wie ich es beschreiben soll,
aber es erfordert halt so ein bisschen mehr Arbeit.
So, das Ding ist jetzt,
wenn man diesen Proof of Concept Code nimmt
und auch im aktuellen Chrome Browser startet,
dann sieht man den gleichen Error.
gpubuffer.cc
Check failed is detached.
Sieht erst mal nach genau dem gleichen Crash aus.
Das ist erst mal schon mal ein bisschen sass,
aber muss jetzt auch an sich nichts bedeuten,
weil es ging ja auch um eine Sicherheitslücke
nicht im latest Chrome,
sondern halt in einer älteren Version.
Aber wenn wir uns dann mal die Diskussion angucken
von den Chromium Engineers, von den Entwicklern,
wie die diese Sicherheitslücke eben gefixt haben,
die da reported wurde,
dann steht da,
wir adden ein Check, um die Seite zu crashen,
um diese Use-after-Feeling...
Das ist, Susanne,
das ist eigentlich,
das ist ein absichtlicher Crash,
wenn es irgendwie sass aussieht.
Sicherheitslücke zu verhindern,
bevor wir eine bessere Mitigation einbauen.
Man muss jetzt schon hier sagen,
hier waren die Entwickler ein bisschen faul
oder es ist halt ein bisschen unter den Tisch gefallen und so.
Die haben das jetzt nicht,
keinen sauberen Fix gebaut,
aber dieser Check-Fix, diesen Assert,
die gucken halt nach einer Condition,
die halt weird ist,
die halt zu einer Sicherheitslücke führen würde
und bailen einfach aus
und sagen einfach so,
das ist halt so ein bisschen die Lazy-Lösung.
Sie merken so, oh, da passiert was Komisches,
lass mal kurz crashen.
Aber damit ist die Sicherheitslücke halt auch behoben.
Das ist zwar unschön,
dass die Seite irgendwie crasht und so,
das ist halt nicht ganz elegant
und deswegen ist es auch ein To-Do
und deswegen wollten sie es irgendwann mal
noch mal besser machen und so,
aber erst mal ist die Sicherheitslücke gefixt.
Und jetzt vergleicht mal diesen originalen Exploit
von 2022 von David
mit dem Exploit von Jean Pereira jetzt in 2023.
Und das ist jetzt so ein bisschen
wie so ein Kindergartenspiel,
wo du so ein bisschen so zwei Bilder hast
und musst so die Unterschiede feststellen und so weiter
und dann so ein bisschen einrahmen,
wo jetzt die Unterschiede sind und so.
Da muss man jetzt nicht hier programmieren können
oder JavaScript verstehen können.
Wenn man so ein bisschen den Text
letztlich sieht man,
dass der schon sehr ähnlich ist.
Da wurden einfach ein paar Variablen umbenannt
und es wurde minimiert,
es wurde kleiner gemacht.
Das macht eben auch Sinn,
weil eben jetzt der Code eben diesen Check drin hat,
diesen Assert, der getriggert wird.
Du brauchst eben jetzt nicht mehr diesen ganzen Code,
um diese Use-after-free,
also um wirklich die richtige Sicherheitslücke auszunutzen.
Es reicht, wenn du quasi,
dass es für den Check so aussieht,
dass es crasht.
Da bräuchte man ein bisschen mehr Code.
Aber um diesen frühen Check,
der quasi die Sicherheitslücke verhindert,
um den zu triggern,
da reicht ein bisschen weniger Code.
Und John Pereira hat das einfach jetzt minimiert.
Aber wenn ihr das vergleicht,
ist es quasi genau dasselbe.
Aber daran sieht man,
okay, ganz planlos ist er ja nicht.
Also du musst zumindest insofern Wissen darüber,
Bescheid, das angucken.
Und na ja gut,
im Endeffekt nimmst du das Originalbeispiel
und löscht ein paar Sachen raus.
Aber also,
kompletter Ultra-Kack-Noob
wird es wahrscheinlich nicht blicken.
Und deswegen,
wenn man jetzt ein Debug-Bild von Chrome hat,
also ein Bild,
wo man richtig den Quellcode sehen kann,
wo man richtig so sich angucken kann,
wo der Fehler und so passiert.
Ich habe einmal versucht,
by the way,
ich habe einmal versucht,
eine Chrome selbst zu kompilieren.
Das braucht ja so unglaublich viel RAM.
Da hatte ich irgendwann keinen Bock mehr.
Wenn man jetzt also John Pereiras Code nimmt
und diesen alten Exploit-Code nimmt
und den in der aktuellen Version
und drei Bildsysteme oder so
und sich den Stacktrace anguckt,
was genau passiert,
dann sieht man hier,
der ist genau identisch.
Jetzt könnte es natürlich noch sein,
vielleicht hat er ja collaborated.
Vielleicht ist er ja in Verbindung
mit diesem Researcher.
Vielleicht hat er das zusammen
mit diesem Typ gefunden.
Vielleicht hat auch sein Father das gefunden.
Also habe ich die...
Nein, nein,
ich glaube,
16 Gig haben noch nicht mal gereicht.
Also das war wirklich krass.
Also erstmal ist Chrome-Kompilieren
eine Wissenschaft für sich.
Du brauchst irgendwie
drei verschiedene Bildsysteme,
musst dir jetzt zig Sachen runterladen,
in der richtigen Reihenfolge machen
und das braucht RAM
und auch Disk-Space und so.
Das ist wirklich...
Also nichts,
was ich in meiner Linux-VR
mal nebenbei machen konnte.
Dieser David Manu Sherry
hat einfach mal eine Nachricht
auf Twitter geschrieben.
Weil wir Hacker,
wir sind halt sehr connected
auf Twitter und so weiter
und er folgt mir auch,
habe ich gesehen
und ich habe ihm auch schon gefreut.
Die Hackermäns sind am Start.
Also schreibe ich ihm einfach
mal eine DM und frage ihn mal.
Ich übersetze mal auf Deutsch.
Ich habe ihn gefragt,
hey, ist das hier dein Report?
Kennst du übrigens Jean Pereira?
Und schau dir mal
diesen Proof of Concept
von Jean Pereira an.
Sieht das so aus wie dein Exploit?
Und da schreibt er,
ja, ist quasi identisch.
Und das,
wenn man es mit seinem Pock vergleicht,
ist wirklich nur
ein paar Buchstaben anders
und dass die Variablen Namen
sogar basierend sind auf seinem Code.
Also Adapter wurde abgekürzt zu A,
Device wurde abgekürzt zu D,
GPU Buffer wurde abgekürzt zu B.
Also auch hier,
das ist alles irgendwie
ein bisschen sass.
Und David Manu Sherry
hat gesagt,
das hätte ich wahrscheinlich
auch noch hinbekommen.
Ich habe noch,
hat noch nie was von dem gehört
und ich kann es nicht
oft genug sagen,
aber Browser Exploitation
ist wirklich Top Tier Hacking.
Und wenn du da dazugehörst,
dann bist du auch bekannt.
Und wenn du nicht bekannt bist,
dann weil du nicht bekannt sein willst,
dann bist du auch
nicht so ein Öffentlichkeitstyp.
Also es gibt auf jeden Fall Hacker,
die vor allem in irgendwelchen Firmen arbeiten,
wo das dann verkauft wird
zu irgendwelchen Government Agencies
und so weiter.
Die sind dann vielleicht nicht öffentlich.
Die stehen dann auch nicht auf der Bühne
und geben irgendwelche Talks und so weiter.
Die sind dann sehr privat für sich,
reporten einfach ihr Zeug,
kassieren ihr Bug Bounty,
verkaufen die Vulnerabilities
und so weiter und kassieren Geld
und so weiter.
Die stehen da nicht da.
Aber jemand,
der so öffentlich ist
und sich so öffentlich präsentiert,
da würde man meinen,
dass er bekannt ist
in der Browser Exploitation Szene
und dass andere Researcher
ihn auch kennen.
Dann wird es halt wieder schwierig.
Unterstellt man ihm jetzt,
dass er diesen Exploit Code
einfach copy and pasted hat,
ein bisschen was umbenannt hat,
ein bisschen minimiert hat,
ein bisschen kleiner gemacht hat
und so weiter
und claimt jetzt,
er hat das gebaut?
Naja, er hat jetzt nicht gesagt,
er hat das gefunden.
Er ist nur dieser Autor
dieses Minimizing.
Also das kann man vielleicht
einfach mal so sagen.
Er hat jetzt nicht gelogen vielleicht,
aber ich finde das schon
so ein bisschen misleading
und ein bisschen täuschen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Dazu muss man auch sagen,
ihr kennt das sicherlich von YouTube.
Zwei unterschiedliche YouTuber
beschäftigen sich mit demselben Thema
und machen dasselbe Video
und man denkt so,
der eine hat vom anderen geklaut,
aber eigentlich hatten sie
zufällig dieselbe Idee.
Das passiert in IT Security auch ständig.
Wir nennen das dann Bug Collision,
wenn zwei Security Researcher
denselben Security Bug
quasi gleichzeitig finden.
Das passiert einfach.
Also es könnte auch sein,
dass Jean Pereira einfach zufällig
über genau denselben Issue gelaufen ist.
Und das kann ich jetzt
halt nicht beweisen.
Also ich kann jetzt nicht beweisen,
dass er wirklich diesen Code genommen hat
und copy and pasted hat
und geändert hat.
Mein Eindruck ist,
das könnte man unterstellen,
aber wie gesagt,
ich kann es nicht beweisen
und es könnte auch einfach sein,
dass es zufällig gleich war.
Dazu kommt aber jetzt
auch noch die Einschätzung
aus seinem Talk,
wo er das nämlich
so richtig einordnet.
Also ich kann jetzt nicht
beweisen,
dass er wirklich
so richtig einordnet.
Wobei das ja auch immer
komplett unterschiedliche
Angriffsvektoren sind.
Bei dem einen greifst du von außen
auf irgendeinen Webserver zu.
Ja, wenn du es damit schaffst,
ihn zu crashen, ist kacke.
Aber ob ich jetzt direkt an den,
was schon habe auf dem Server,
was da läuft und direkt da dran komme
und mit dem Prozess was machen kann
oder über das Netzwerk da dran muss,
sind ja schon mal
ganz, ganz viele Dinge.
Also ich glaube,
dass es nicht einfach so ist,
dass wir einfach
einen User After 3 Bug machen
und dann können wir
das nicht einfach
in die Erinnerung
bringen
und das ist ja auch
so eine Art
der Abschätzung
von der Version.
Das heißt,
wenn ich jetzt
einen User After 3 Bug
hervorrufe,
ich kann das nicht
irgendwie auch
einfach
verhindern,
dass er
ein User After 3 Bug
macht.
Also,
das ist
eine Art
dem Bamboo-Fuzzer, ob seiner Meinung nach, weil er hat ja wirklich erfahren...
Oh, da kommt jetzt irgendein vernichtendes Urteil zu Bamboo.js.
...ob er denkt, dass dieser Fuzzer hat was finden können und so.
Und ja, er sagt auch, das sieht nicht nach einem Capable-Fuzzer aus.
Und er ist zwar auch vorsichtig und sagt so, man kann halt immer Glück haben beim Fuzzing und so,
der könnte schon was gefunden haben, aber es sieht nicht legit aus.
Und er hat auch noch nie was von ihm gehört, er hat noch nie mit ihm zusammengearbeitet und sonst was.
Ich habe mal die Nachrichten eingeblendet, da macht euch ein eigenes Bild drüber.
Oder das ist jetzt wirklich die Einschätzung von einem, der legit wirklich Browser-Exploits gefunden hat.
Also wenn ihr quasi nicht mir glaubt, weil ich habe sowas ja noch nie gefunden, dann vielleicht glaubt ihr ja ihm.
Aber wir sind noch nicht ganz fertig.
Aber jetzt wird es wieder, jetzt haben wir ein bisschen das Technische überstanden,
jetzt wird es wieder ein bisschen untechnischer.
Und zwar war dieser Kommentar auch unter Leroy's Video.
Und der fand es auch so ein bisschen komisch, dass da irgendwie eine Webseite referenziert wird auf LinkedIn
und dann die Domain ist dann irgendwie Counterswarm und er hat auch keine Connections zu aktuellen IT-Security-Namen.
Ja, weil er...
...irgendwie halt irgendwie in seiner eigenen Bubble irgendwie existiert.
Und dann war er auch irgendwie Inhaber von Secbiz und so.
Und dann schreibt die Person halt, entweder hat der Typ schon mehrere No-Name-IT-Security-Firmen gegründet
oder der ist ein bisschen shady.
So, ich kann jetzt auf LinkedIn nicht mehr...
Ich...
Mein Eindruck wäre auch gewesen, das ist etwas shady, ja.
Nachgucken, weil wie gesagt, der hat mich ja blockiert.
Aber jemand anders hat mir diesen Screenshot geschickt und da claimt er halt bei der Citrus GmbH,
dass er da irgendwie seit 13 Jahren arbeitet.
Ja, die Citrus GmbH, die existiert jetzt halt erst seit gerade eben.
Da kann er jetzt nicht 30 Jahre gearbeitet haben.
Aber ich...
Geil.
Ich meine, er hat halt irgendwie selbstständig schon irgendwie seit 13 Jahren gearbeitet.
Halt in anderen Firmen hat irgendwie...
20 Jahre Kubernetes-Erfahrung, Leute, ja.
...Firmen gegründet und so.
Das ist halt wieder so ein bisschen so...
Ich würde jetzt sagen, das ist jetzt nicht vielleicht unbedingt eine Lüge.
Also er hat als Head of Research oder so quasi schon immer gearbeitet,
hat einfach seinen eigenen Titel erfunden oder sowas.
Ist ja auch okay.
Aber das sieht halt natürlich erst mal komisch aus.
Und ich finde...
Also es ist für mich immer ein Anzeichen von, dass da irgendwas nicht stimmt.
Also wenn Sachen weggelassen werden und aufgebläht werden,
so nach dem Motto, durch das Weglassen falsche Eindrücke entstehen.
Das ist immer so.
Ich denke, okay, wenn man das nötig hat, da muss doch irgendwas...
Ist da doch.
Ich finde, das ist auch wieder so ein bisschen misleading und irgendwie so...
Ich weiß nicht, gilt das als Täuschung oder so?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Weil das quasi das Unternehmen hinstellt,
das wäre ein langjähriges, seriöses, laufendes Unternehmen seit 13 Jahren.
Aber stattdessen ist das eine Neugründung.
Und das ist auch alles so verwirrend.
Und der hat auch irgendwie diese Counter-Swarm-Webseite.
Und ich erinnere mich, dass er da eben als Geschäftsführer drin stand.
Aber da steht er jetzt nicht mehr drin.
Ich habe dann im Webarchiv nachgeguckt.
Im Webarchiv sieht man halt, als die Citrus GmbH in Gründung war,
stand er da als Geschäftsführer drin.
Jetzt ist nur jemand anders Geschäftsführer, ein Kai Probeil.
Aber ich glaube halt eben, er ist da nicht nur Angestellter,
sondern er hat diese Firma mitgegründet.
Ich habe jetzt nicht im Handelsregister oder so nachgeguckt,
ob er jetzt Gesellschafter ist.
Aber ich würde jetzt einfach mal vermuten,
und ich finde, das ist jetzt auch nicht abwegig,
diese Vermutung anzustellen, dass er Geschäftsanteile
von dieser Firma hat, dass er die mitgegründet hat.
Also da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher halt.
Und dann hat er halt eben diese Zegbis-IT-Security,
die ist auch inzwischen geschlossen, die gibt es jetzt auch nicht mehr.
Und dann irgendwie unter diesem Talk, den er gemacht hat,
noch einen Kommentar gefunden, wieso Zegbis irgendwie vor wurde
zu High Kiki, wo dann wiederum jemand anders geschrieben hat,
das wäre JP's neue Firma.
Alter, wer blickt da noch durch?
Und da gibt es eben diese High Kiki GmbH mit einem Nikolas Flatt und so.
Also mit dem er scheinbar dann wahrscheinlich auch das gegründet hatte
und da involviert war oder sowas.
Das ist halt alles so ein bisschen weird.
Und das jetzt hören und sagen, das weiß ich jetzt selber nicht,
das habe ich jetzt nicht so nachempfunden.
Das hat mir nur jemand erzählt und vielleicht habe ich es auch falsch verstanden
und vielleicht ist es auch dieses Game of Telephone,
wo sich die Story so ein bisschen verändert und so weiter.
Deshalb hier ein riesiger Disclaimer, dass das vielleicht nicht stimmt und so weiter.
Das sagen Leute quasi hinter seinem Rücken so über ihn oder sowas.
Das ist nicht meine Meinung.
Es wird quasi so gesagt, dass er ständig Firmen gründen würde,
um dann eben irgendwelche Services zu verkaufen.
Und dann ist die Firma halt plötzlich weg.
Er schließt die wieder und arbeitet wieder an was,
und ich habe mit einer Person tatsächlich Kontakt gehabt,
wo seine Firma mal wohl Kunde von Jean-Pierre war oder sowas.
Und die waren wohl unzufrieden und haben dann auch die Arbeit mit ihm beendet.
Aber ich kann das nicht verifizieren.
Ich habe dafür keine Beweise und so weiter.
Das war nur eine Instagram Nachricht, die ich bekommen habe.
Wie gesagt, hören und sagen, nicht meine Meinung.
Aber das sind halt immer so, wie man schwäbisch sagen würde,
hinterlässt ein bisschen Geschmäckle.
So, okay.
Vielen Dank für alle, die jetzt so weit geguckt haben.
So, lass mich das mal noch so ein bisschen einordnen.
Ich liebe Hacking.
Hacking, IT-Security.
IT-Security ist eine Kunst.
Ist wirklich wahnsinnig.
Ich habe so Respekt vor Leuten, die Sicherheitslücken finden.
Ja, richtig gutes Video.
Gebe ich euch recht.
Und ich liebe den Bereich.
Ich liebe einfach am Computer zu sitzen und mich mit den Themen zu beschäftigen.
Und deswegen habe ich auch diesen YouTube-Kanal, weil ich eben das mit...
Ich hoffe, ich konnte ein bisschen was Sinnvolles zu erzählen,
auch als nicht hauptberuflicher Hacker mehr in der Welt teilen möchte.
Und ich möchte den Leuten diese richtig geilen Sicherheitslücken und so erklären.
Ich liebe das halt.
Aber es gibt halt auch so ein bisschen so einen Community-Aspekt.
Weißt du so, man muss sich den Respekt so ein bisschen verdienen und so.
Und Jean-Pierre scheint mir jemand zu sein,
der schon ein gutes...
Grundwissen hat.
Ich meine, er macht das jetzt auch schon eine ganze Weile.
Auch wenn das vieles overhyped ist und vielleicht ein bisschen misleading
und in meiner Meinung nach zum Beispiel bei dem Hospital Run eindeutig fake war,
würde ich grundsätzlich schon sagen, der Typ hat schon IT-Ahnung.
Das ist jetzt nicht einer, der komplett Bullshit redet.
Der sagt schon auch richtige Sachen.
Und deshalb finde ich das so erstaunlich,
wieso er irgendwie dieses Overhyping und das negative Kommentare löschen und so weiter macht.
Zum Beispiel diesen...
Ja, weil Comedy-Gruppe...
...Security-Issue, die er gefunden hat.
Da kann er stolz drauf sein.
Das ist eine coole Sicherheitslücke.
Das macht sich richtig gut im Lebenslauf.
Ich kann das einfach nicht nachvollziehen,
wieso man auf der einen Seite offensichtlich das Wissen hat
und versteht, was XSS-Sicherheitslücken hat,
die man in irgendeiner Stadtverwaltung oder sowas findet.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber dann das irgendwie so aufbauschen muss und so.
Andererseits kann ich halt auch verstehen,
dass so unsere Industrie leider funktioniert.
Also man sieht das halt sehr viel von Firmen,
von so Security-Service-Firmen.
Und ihr seht das auch in der VPN-Werbung,
die halt Leroy gemacht hat,
dass halt so mit Angstmacherei geworben wird und so.
Und da wird immer dieser dunkle Hacker, böse Hacker,
in alle Devices irgendwie reinhacken kann,
immer so hingestellt und so weiter,
weil das ermöglicht dann halt Firmen irgendwie so Services zu verkaufen
und irgendwelche Security-Solutions zu verkaufen.
Da ging halt VPNs gar nichts dagegen.
Verkaufen.
Und das sieht man halt...
Da habe ich ja sogar auch schon mal ein Video zu gemacht,
was NordVPN nicht gefallen hat.
...in der generellen IT-Security-Industrie halt ständig.
Das fuckt richtig ab.
Das nervt mich richtig und so.
Und das nervt auch viele Hacker und so.
Andererseits halt, ja, Businesses machen halt Geld
und die werben halt damit.
Und solange da irgendwie niemand was sagt,
dann weiß ich nicht, kommt man halt damit halt auch durch.
Jean-Pierre hat so ein bisschen das Problem,
dass er halt nicht als anonyme Firma auftritt,
sondern halt als Person, die halt bekannt ist,
die man halt kennt.
Und dann kratzt der halt so ein bisschen an dem Ego
von uns anderen Hackern und so.
Und ich kann das...
Ja, verständlich.
Verständlich.
Ich finde es auch immer nervig, wenn einer so...
Guck mal, ich finde es auch immer nervig,
wenn in irgendeiner Fernsehsendung
irgendwelche IT-Szenen gezeigt werden
oder in irgendwelchen Serien oder so,
die komplett weg von der Realität sind.
Da denke ich mir auch immer, Alter,
was zeigt dir da für ein Blödsinn?
Und so fühlt sich das halt...
Das hört sich halt auch an.
Du denkst dir, okay, das ist alles so vage und so.
Und da fehlt so die Substanz.
Und dann denkst du so,
aber eigentlich wirft das jetzt ja dann auch
ein schlechtes Licht irgendwie auf Leute,
die das legit machen.
Kann ich verstehen.
Manfly, nee, du, danke schön für die Subs.
Ich habe ja euch irgendwie übersehen.
Ich finde, ihr könnt ja auch eine erfolgreiche
IT-Security-Karriere haben,
ohne dieses Overhyping und so weiter.
Es ist dann halt schwieriger,
irgendwie bei Heise in irgendwelchen Artikeln und so zu landen.
Und auch schwieriger vielleicht bei Leroy
als Interviewpartner eingeladen zu werden.
Aber meiner Meinung nach ist das nicht nötig.
In IT-Security kann man so einfach viel Geld verdienen.
Die Firmen suchen weltweit nach Security-Leuten und so.
Man muss natürlich einiges mitbringen.
IT-Security ist nicht etwas, wo man einfach so reinkommt.
Also für mich ist das schon so ein Tiefgang
in die Informatik und so weiter.
Und ich finde, für richtiges Hacking
muss man schon echt tiefes Computerwissen haben.
Das ist schon eine krasse Spezialisierung.
Und da muss man schon einige Jahre dran sitzen.
Es ist jetzt nicht, dass man da so super einfach reinkommt.
Aber man kommt einfach rein.
Man muss halt ein bisschen Zeit investieren.
Und Jean Pereira, meiner Meinung nach,
hat auch das Wissen und das Level, dass er da drin ist.
Deshalb, ja, ich kann es einfach nicht verstehen,
wieso man mit solchen Mitteln irgendwie spielen muss.
Und falls ihr wirklich das bis zum Ende geschaut habt,
wollte ich nochmal ein paar Recommendations geben.
Und vielleicht für Leroy einen anderen deutschen Hacker,
den er einladen könnte.
Es gibt zum Beispiel Florian Dalbeck von Algorithmen verstehen
oder Morpheus Tutorials.
Beide habe ich schon mal getroffen und so weiter.
Und die sind solide Hacker, die IT-Security verstehen
und meiner Meinung nach viel besser einordnen
und so weiter.
Ganz ehrlich, den Florian, der da einladen soll,
das wäre sicherlich besser gewesen.
... schon professioneller einordnen können,
ohne dieses ganze Kinderkrams, Anonymous-Bullshit.
Und man könnte auch zum Beispiel den Chaos Computer Club kontaktieren.
Linus Neumann, der ist immer wahrscheinlich zu haben
für so Pressemitteilungen oder so.
Den könnt ihr Leroy auf jeden Fall interviewen.
Der kann das auch viel besser einordnen und so.
Und für die ganzen Schüler und Studenten unter euch,
es gibt auch den Deutschen Verein Nachwuchsförderung für IT-Sicherheit.
Und da bin ich auch quasi Gründungsmitglied davon.
Es gibt einen Discord, wo ja andere,
IT-Security-interessierte junge Leute kennenlernen können.
Und einmal im Jahr veranstaltet auch die Enfitz
die Cyber Security Challenge Germany.
Das ist so ein Wettbewerb, wo man als Schüler und Student mitmachen kann
und so Sicherheitslücken und so lösen kann.
Und dann gibt es ein Finale
und dann gibt es auch die European Cyber Security Challenge
und so, da kann man dann rein und so.
Das ist richtig cool, das macht richtig Bock.
Ich habe damals auch mitgemacht.
Ich bin der Two-Time, ich habe zweimal die Cyber Security Challenge Germany gewonnen.
Hanna Flex am Ende.
Das lief jetzt gerade erst, das wird also erst wieder nächstes Jahr stattfinden
und so weiter, aber checkt einfach mal den Discord aus
oder folgt halt den CSI.
Dann bekommt ihr auch mit, wenn das wieder startet und so.
Und ich kann das euch wirklich nur ans Herz legen,
wenn ihr da Bock drauf habt und so.
Das ist euer Weg in die legit IT-Security-Welt
und das ist wirklich eine tolle Karriere.
Man muss da wirklich viel reinchecken und so,
aber man kann da auch viel reißen und das macht auch richtig Bock
und ich liebe diesen Job einfach.
Und damit wäre es das gewesen.
Wir arbeiten übrigens auch an unserer eigenen Trainingsplattform
hackstreet.io, aber wir sind noch nicht so weit,
ist noch nicht öffentlich.
Und natürlich checkt auch meinen Hauptkanal Live Overflow.
Am besten guckt in die Playlist, da gibt es ein paar Playlists.
Vielleicht findet ihr ein Thema,
was euch interessiert und dann guckt euch mal die Playlists an.
Und wenn ich jetzt noch so ein Make-A-Wish-Wunsch hätte
oder sowas, so richtig dreist,
so richtig unangenehm am Ende,
so eine kleine Bitte, was mir richtig Freude machen würde,
einfach so als kleiner Fan.
Like, subscribe.
Und ich weiß, als Influencer ist das auch scheiße,
wenn jemand sowas sagt, aber ich bin jetzt einfach mal so assi,
weil ich auch eh nicht auf dem deutschen Markt unterwegs bin.
Das wäre so ein kleiner Dream-Come-True,
wenn Stay-Off ein Video von mir reagieren würde.
Das war meine unangenehme Bitte.
Am Ende, ich verziehe mich schon.
Ciao.
Das boostet vor allem noch mal ein bisschen hier.
Wenn ich eingeloggt wäre, würde ich ihn auch direkt subskribieren,
wie das mein Englischlehrer mal gesagt hat.
Letztens eine Werbung gehört im Radio.
Da habe ich auch gedacht, irgendjemand hat das super schlecht übersetzt.
Das war für irgendeinen Reiseveranstalter oder so.
Oder für eine Fluggesellschaft.
Ich weiß nicht.
Zumindest haben die gesagt in diesem Werbespot,
wir fliegen sie zu verschiedenen Destinationen.
Da dachte ich mir auch so, was?
Wer hat sich das denn überlegt?
Könnten wir das nicht einfach Urlaubsorte, Ziele oder sonst was nennen?
Zu vielen Destinationen?
Klingt einfach dumm auf Deutsch, oder?
Genauso wie subskribieren.
Okay.
Leute, wisst ihr, was jetzt ist?
Ihr kommt nie drauf.
Und ratet mal, was es heute gibt.
Und ich glaube, heute liegt ihr richtig.
Bettke, nein.
Bettke um 12 vor 4 noch nicht.
Nudel mit Lachs.
Richtig.
Gibt tatsächlich seit etwas längerer Zeit mal wieder.
Nudel mit Lachs.
Also, ich bin mal auf.
Wir sehen uns die Tage.
Bis denn.
Cu.
Ach ja, wer noch nicht gefollowt hat und öfters dabei sein will, würde ich mich natürlich auch über ein Follow freuen.
Bisschen Sellout.
Und es ist der erste, sehe ich gerade.
Bald ist wieder Abo-Sellout-Time angesagt.
Also, bis denn.
Cu macht's gut.